[Music]
they assured me we're not going to give
you a lavalier the mics will be on this
is the massachusetts institute of
technology and this is how we start the
day it's my pleasure as the executive
vice president of the alumni association
to welcome all of you this morning to
tech day 2004
the committee and staff working on the
program have put together another
stunning day of academic interest with
time for q a discussion with the
presenters and we're very excited about
the program we are living on the edge a
little bit this morning we're scheduled
at 11 45 to have our alumnus traveling
the furthest for his reunion to join us
from the international space station
and we hope that all will go well with
nasa and we'll be able to talk as in
addition to uh talking about the
automobile this morning to get a little
report from space
there has been a change in the afternoon
programming there will be a wonderful
opportunity for i think more discussion
we tend to pack these programs so
tightly with speakers that sometimes
speaker cancellations are a blessing
this afternoon we will have norman
augustine dean cayman and ernest moniz
and have time to really talk about some
important issues with them
i wanted to recognize
all of the good friends here
and the people i hope will soon be good
friends
for your continued support of mit and i
wanted to especially pay tribute to to
one special guest it was noted at
commencement yesterday that it was the
first time in 44 years that paul gray
was not on the commencement stage paul
has been on that stage as a faculty
member chancellor president chairman and
now again as a faculty member for the
last 44 years but yesterday he was
instead marching with his 50th reunion
class as the class president and i think
for that remarkable achievement we owe
paul and priscilla a round of applause
paul and i were discussing this
yesterday i believe that must be a
record although he thinks that perhaps
president killian spent as many years on
the stage but i suspect paul will
surpass that in the future
it's my pleasure to introduce our
morning moderator the day will be
split into two sessions this morning
moderated by president vest in the
afternoon by our distinguished guest
norman augustine
chuck needs no introduction to this
crowd
he is mit's 15th president and
conveniently for our topic today and our
guest speaker he chaired the president's
advisory committee on the redesign of
the space station in 1993 and 94. so he
knows far more about this than the rest
of us and we're delighted to have this
opportunity to feature that today
chuck needs no introduction but he
deserves our biggest applause for his
bold and disciplined disciplined
leadership of mit for the past 14 years
without further ado president best
thank you beth and good morning everyone
over the last few years you've heard a
great deal about so-called disruptive
technologies
phrase uh coined by clay christensen up
at the harvard business school
disruptive technologies are those
innovations that have the potential to
truly change the way we live to
transform the economy
and in the end to reshape our world
today's technology day program
is designed to discuss what certainly
has to be
the greatest disruptive technology of
all time namely the automobile
over the course of the last hundred
years or so the automobile has spawned
entirely new industries
remade cities and spurred the growth of
suburbs and ex-burbs and come to play an
increasingly important part in our daily
lives
now i'm going to be honest with you at
this point in my speech
this little sentence in bracket says
tell some anecdotes about your personal
experiences with cars
but i figure
that if i got started on our family's 36
ford
my 49 chevy or my 49 plymouth
my 54 volkswagen or even my 1985
dodge airy station wagon with a stick
shift
we'd be here all day so let's hear from
some people that really know about this
industry
for most of this period the united
states has been thought of as a car
culture but since world war ii the
private automobile has actually been
transforming europe as well
it has played an enormous role in the
development of contemporary japan and
south korea
and is now beginning to make its mark in
china and other rapidly emerging
economies
there is no doubt that the automobile
has been and remains a powerful symbol
of personal freedom
an important engine for both economic
opportunity
and for leisure
but there is at the same time no doubt
that it has troubling consequences as
well
in consumption of energy
the production of environmental
pollutants and in land use and community
planning
in other words the automobile is a
powerful technology that in fact is
still developing
and that has profound economic but also
social and policy impact as well
if that doesn't sound like the kind of a
subject that mit ought to be concerned
about i don't know what is
in fact there are exactly
these are exactly the kinds of issues
and problems that mit as you know seeks
to tackle
places where the world needs our
expertise and our vision
so it is not surprising that we have
been involved for many decades with
questions raised by the automobile
as far back as 1929
a generous gift from alfred p sloane jr
provided for the establishment of the
sloan automotive laboratory which
remains an international center of
research in automotive and engine
technologies
during the 1980s and 90s the automobile
was at the center
of mit's groundbreaking studies of
industrial productivity and
competitiveness that began to develop
during paul gray's presidency at a time
in which as you know the manufacturing
sector of our economy was deeply
threatened
and today work on issues related to the
automobile continues across the
institute as we develop both new
automotive technologies and a new
understanding of the car's social and
environmental impact
the impact of this work is leveraged
through collaboration with many
stakeholders from industry from
government and from non-governmental
organizations ngos
this morning we will hear about central
challenges and opportunities before us
today
about the automobile's economic impact
its fundamental technologies
its impact on the developing world
and its role in individual lives
this afternoon session will look to the
future
encouraging us to think about resources
the relationship of the car to urban
life
and the possibility of alternatives
this morning our first speaker is going
to be professor dan roos
dan is the associate dean for
engineering systems in the school of
engineering and the co-director of our
engineering systems division
a member of the mit class of 1961
he holds the japan steel industry
professorship of engineering
dan is going to talk to us about the
automotive sector future challenges and
opportunities
but i can't help insert dan at this
point a little anecdote that says
something about the quality of your work
and the work of mit in general
rather early in my presidency not too
long after dan's remarkable book
the machine that changed the world about
productivity and lean manufacturing in
the automobile industry came out
i had a trip to germany on behalf of mit
and had an appointment to spend an hour
with the then chairman of the then
company daimler-benz
and i had been warned up one side and
down the other that everybody at
daimler-benz recognized their company
and its miserable productivity and
quality ratings in the anonymous
companies in dan's book watch out they
said this is a big powerful european
chairman he's going to beat you up
so i walked in with great fear and
trepidation
said hello and so forth sat down
and he looked over at me and he said
that book that you guys wrote at mit
it's going to have more positive impact
on this company than anything that's
ever happened
and that's exactly what we want to have
happen here and i think indeed
dan's work had impact not only there but
around the world
following dan we'll hear from another
extraordinary mit colleague who
absolutely anybody who knows anything
about engines and combustion and
automotive technology knows and looks to
as one of the great gurus our colleague
professor john haywood
john currently is the sanjay professor
of mechanical engineering and the
director of the sloan automotive
laboratory that i mentioned a moment ago
john will discuss future automotive
technology and fuels the options and
their impact
following
the talks the remarks by dan and john
the three of us will then go to the
other side of the stage and we will open
up for about 15 minutes of question and
answer with you before the mid-morning
break dan
you're asking if you're pleased to take
your name tag off when you speak
thanks
it's a pleasure and privilege to be here
today
i'm here wearing two hats a speaker
in this technology day
and as was mentioned earlier
i am also here as an alumni of mit
and a member of the class of 1961.
so i thought it might be interesting to
take a look at what a
car looked like in 1961.
the 1961 chrysler imperial getting about
eight miles per gallon
with tail fins like i could have put a
cadillac in which had about three times
as tall tail fits
now bear in mind that it wasn't until
1965 that ralph nader rode unsafe at any
speed
there was no environmental protection
agency as a matter of fact there was no
department of transportation
japanese cars were not being sold in the
united states at that point in time
so things have really changed in a very
very significant way
uh chuck very eloquently mentioned why
the automobile is so important to us uh
from a societal point of view in terms
of its economic impact
from a personal point of view it
provides us with mobility to let us work
to get to work to shop entertainment
and from a societal point of view as
well
so when we think of the automobile
we we have to think of it
in an overall context of an automotive
system
there's the infrastructure upon which
the vehicle is going to operate which is
being subjected to increased congestion
there's the urban environment and the
impact of both the vehicles and the
infrastructure on that environment
there are concerns about sustainability
the impact on our environment
particularly with regard to urban air
pollution and global warming
and other societal concerns fuel
efficiency
energy conservation
automotive safety the
disposal and recycling of vehicles and
some new concerns
issues like road rage
and more recently
for those of you who have been following
all of the
debate and concern about obesity
joining the fast food chains as one of
the primary villains is the automobile
with the implication being and probably
correct implementation because people
are driving so much they're walking less
so this is a technology that has had as
chuck said a really
significant impact on all of us and also
as chuck indicated
the growth and use of automobiles is
increasing all over the world this is
not a u.s phenomenon we have become a
dependent society on the automobile
public transportation is an important
but unfortunately
it plays a minor role in terms of the
amount of passenger travel
that it carries and that role is
decreasing and it's decreasing even
in the major
large high-density cities of the world
the cities that were really developed
around public transportation
the public has expressed their desire
for the comfort the convenience of
automobile travel they like a more
low-density
lifestyle
and so we really have become an
auto-dependent society there's no
alternative to the
automobile today i'd like to begin
looking at
what's happening in the auto industry
and then look at the future in terms of
what auto production may look like where
the future markets will be
some of the challenges that we have with
respect to highway congestion
automobiles in the urban environment and
and finally a few comments about the
implications
for
mit
automobile manufacturing in the u.s has
changed drastically
in the 1980s all japanese cars sold in
the united states were manufactured in
japan
today the big three
chrysler gm and ford the american
producers are closing manufacturing
plants at the same time the japanese
companies are opening up manufacturing
facilities in the united states
largely as a result of globalization
and it's not just manufacturing
facilities it's research and development
it's design centers so that these r d
and design centers are designing
vehicles for american taste that are
going to then be manufactured at
american plants
50 000
americans are employed now in japanese
manufacturing plants in the us producing
over 2 million cars a year
the implication of this is that we
really have two auto industries in this
country
we have the big three which is detroit
based and unionized and then we have the
so-called transplants the foreign plants
and these are not just japanese
mercedes bmw also are manufacturing cars
here
they're not detroit based they tend to
be primarily in the south they're all
non-union in spite of the efforts of the
united auto workers to unionize them
as the plant as the big three plants
have closed we have this very
unfortunate imbalance of more retirees
than active workers 370 000 retirees
and only 290 000 active workers in the
big three
the implications of that are severe in
terms of legacy costs for health care
and pension
it cost the big three about 1
360 a car
versus about 80 to 107 a car for toyota
and honda
furthermore
union contracts specify that if workers
are laid off they still get paid
this has led general motors to continue
auto production at a constant level
during the recession
the result of that has been an
oversupply of cars the only way to get
rid of those cars is to offer these
incredible rebates which you're seeing
you know five thousand dollars or more
per car zero percent financing
and the other manufacturers have had to
respond to compete
this has had a major impact on
profitability
general motors does not make money
selling cars in the united states
general motors makes money in auto
financing
in home mortgages dytec.com
and in selling cars in the asia pacific
market
we've seen an unfortunate gradual
decline in the market share of the big
three in 1978 they had 84 of the market
here in the us
today
in 2003 61
the may figures just came out a few days
ago and the market share is now below 60
percent
in addition to this there's increased
competition from korea
hyundai for many years was had a
reputation for very very poor quality
and now it's rated extremely high from a
quality point of view and hyundai is the
fastest growing car company in the
united states
in addition u.s consumers
have a much greater choice of the cars
to buy
between 1974 and 2004
there has been a doubling of the nut of
the different types of models available
to u.s consumers
so we have volkswagen the so-called
people's car company manufacturing
inexpensive cars that now this year for
the first time is selling the phaeton
in the us prices start at 65 000 and go
to 125 000
if you think that is a lot of money
to pay for a car think again
daimler which produces mercedes
has come out with the maybach
350 000
to buy a maybach
at the same time that mercedes
that daimler is moving upscale they're
also moving downscale
so next year you will be able to buy
the smart vehicle which is currently in
europe this is a mini car
bmw will be introducing the bmw 1 series
there are new market segments
toyota for example is offering
a hybrid gasoline electric car as is
honda this is the prius it's now second
generation
toyota has found that their market share
among youth was dropping so they come
out with a new product line interesting
looking vehicle this is the skion
so what's happening is
the number of market segments is
increasing
each manufacturer feels a need to to
cover every market segment so there's
great duplication they're all chasing
market share and there's only so much
market share
they're moving upscale they're moving
downscale you combine this
with general motors overproduction of
cars with the new competition from korea
and there is a huge a significant
worldwide problem of over capacity this
is a troubled industry and it shows in
profitability
periodically each one of these companies
has been in pretty dire financial
straits you might have seen about two
weeks ago that mitsubishi just got
bailed out by
one of the japanese banks volkswagen
fiat
have major problems right now
the only car company
which is in really good financial shape
is toyota
the market capitalization of toyota is
greater than the combined market
capitalization of gm ford and daimler
chrysler to give you some idea
but let's talk about the future and what
auto production would look like and
let's start with the car buying process
this is an ad from the boston globe that
i cut out about a week ago
for one of boston's major car dealers
herb chambers
and herb chambers advertises over 1 000
new vehicles in stock
think for a moment of the carrying cost
of 1 000 vehicles in stock
the land that those thousand vehicles
sit on
let's assume that a vehicle goes for 20k
not unreasonable assumption
20 million dollars of inventory is
sitting on that dealer's lot
herb chambers made estimates or one
might say guesstimates of what cars
people would like
but he doesn't always guess right so
here we are about to see the 2005 cars
arrive and we still have brand new 2003
cars left over
so if any of you are interested herb is
having a blowout sale
to get rid of his 2003's
this
excess inventory is symptomatic
of major inefficiencies in the car
production process
manufacturing takes only 1.5 days of
what is a 40-day process
from the time a dealer places an order
with the factory to when that vehicle is
delivered takes 40 days
it is essentially an industry push
system where on a quarterly basis
each manufacturer determines how many
cars of each model is going to be
produced
sometimes they're right sometimes
they're wrong sometimes there are too
many sometimes there aren't enough
instead the industry needs to move
to a customer pull operation
and a bill to order system now bill to
order of course was pioneered by dell
computer
and the automobile is a much more
complicated product than a desktop
computer but nevertheless
chuck mentioned before the machine that
changed the world which was done by the
international motor vehicle program
that program continues here at mit
and the researchers on that program
have estimated and in fact designed a
system where it will take five days from
the time that a customer orders a car
and a dealership to when it's delivered
eliminating the need
for not only all this inventory but
numerous inefficiencies in the supply
chain
and it's ironic but just this week the
book second century which is a follow-on
book to machine to change the world was
published by mit press and so some of
you may be interested in more details
you should read that book
let's talk about automotive markets
the us is basically a replacement market
and western europe
is very minor growth the major growth is
in the developing countries of the world
the motorization of the third world with
a particular focus on china
china has 1.3 billion people
and it's largely an untapped auto market
there are 18.6 vehicles per thousand
people
you can compare that with 300 to 700
vehicles per thousand
in the western world
there's been explosive auto market
growth 3.25 million vehicles built in
2002 that's a 56 percent increase 4.4
million vehicles in 2003 that's a 37
increase
there's improved quality of the cars
that are being produced uh gm shanghai
reports about 23 bad parts per million
delivered compared with three thousand
bad parts per million five years ago
the energy and environmental impacts are
severe and several of our
speakers today will will address those
issues
what is unrecognized
is
the uh what is really a tragedy the
traffic fatality rate in china
last year with 24 million cars there
were 104 deaths now this largely
inexperienced motorists and the large
number of bicyclists
and you compare that with japan which
has three times the number of cars and
the fatalities were 7 000 even in the us
with all the cars that we have the the
auto fatality rate is about 45 000 less
than half of what it is in china
i have grave concern about the auto
industry being overly dependent on china
there are of course great economic
uncertainties if china has a hard
economic landing it will have a hugely
severe impact on this industry it's
obviously going to affect lots of
industries but this industry
in particular
i i was sitting in the front row with
norm augustine and norm just got back uh
from saigon and he was saying boy you
won't believe the traffic there
and you know you go to bangkok
as these developing countries are
motorizing there is this huge huge
congestion and of course the congestion
is developing as well here in the
developed world it's a very major
problem
what i'd like to do
is describe a few very interesting
approaches that some cities are using to
try and minimize the congestion
and how some of those approaches might
suggest what the highway system of the
future is going to look like
in
singapore introduced the first
congestion pricing system in the world
the idea was if a person wanted to
travel into central singapore certain
hours of the day they had to pay a fee
three years ago this system was
automated an electronic road pricing
system was put in place
you can see here
in the vehicle there's an in-vehicle
unit where the driver uses a smart card
to register to go into the city
there's several checkpoints where the
vehicles are checked to make sure
that they have registered
there are two objectives of this system
the first objective is
to encourage people who previously drove
to switch to mass transit and it's been
very successful
the second objective
is to smooth the flow of traffic
throughout the day
so that the charge
varies
by each half hour of the day
if singapore sees that there's a period
of the day when very few people use the
system they're going to put a low charge
on and they'll put a high charge on at
times when lots of people use it causing
people to adjust
the same sort of principles of yield
management in the airline industry and
what electric utilities do to smooth the
utilization of the resource
now this was done in 1975. since then no
other city has implemented congestion
pricing because the politicians were
afraid they said my goodness gracious
what is going to be the backlash from
citizens if they're charged to drive
into the city
that is until this past year when ken
livingston the mayor of
london introduced the congestion pricing
system in london it's within this area
covers about a million people
for those of you not familiar with
london
this would correspond roughly to the
area in manhattan from about 59th street
to the tip of manhattan the financial
district the east side and the west side
travelers need to pay five pounds a day
that's eight dollars
and they can register by phone or
internet or have
a ticket bought at a number of shops
this is not an automated system there
are about 300 surveillance cameras
around this area to check it licenses
and make sure that the drivers are
registered
it's been a tremendous success everybody
was skeptical it would never work
here's some of the data
traffic delays inside the zone are down
30 percent
traffic entering the zone is down 18
of those people have switched to public
transport 20 percent have switched to
another mode primarily taxi
and 25 percent who previously traveled
through the zone but had no interest in
anything in the zone it was simply the
shortest route
now travel around the zone
there's been no adverse traffic impacts
outside the zone
there has been a decline in retail sales
but it's unclear whether that's due to
congestion charging or whether it's due
to the recession which has affected all
retail business in the uk
let's let now look at another uh
interesting approach with pricing
i think many of you are familiar
with the concept of high occupancy
vehicle lanes for car pools van pools
and buses
and this is characteristic of many of
those lanes there's a lot of excess
capacity in those lanes
so the idea is to create from those
lanes high occupancy toll lanes so in
addition to the multi-passenger vehicles
traveling free
single occupant drivers will be allowed
to travel congestion free
in that lane if they pay a fee
variable pricing is used to make sure
that the lane stays congestion free
so if we start to see it build up with
too many cars the price goes up
the price changes every six minutes
so you
you know you're gonna get
a congestive free ride
there are three positive impacts here
first of all those people willing to pay
will get a congestion free ride and at
first they call these lexus lanes you
know the idea they're very rich you know
but it's very interesting they've done
surveys and all income groups are using
them and they're not using them on a
daily basis they're using them when they
really need to get some place quickly
so those people travel congested free
you're taking them off the regular
highway routes and a lot of money is
coming in which can be used to improve
the transportation system
there have been successful
implementations in california and
washington dc of these hot lanes
so successful that maryland and virginia
are now suggesting hot networks be
constructed
and what this suggests is that we will
be moving
to a two-tier or dual network of
highways offering different levels of
service
you will have the existing
congested highway system where you
travel for free
or if you're willing to pay a fee you
can travel on the congested free hot
networks
now both the road pricing system in
singapore
and the hot lanes use electronic toll
collection so that a person doesn't have
to throw money in every day
they're built on a monthly basis
this is one application of an
intelligent transportation system
that links together the driver the
vehicle and the roadway and this has
profound potential impact
there are other examples many of you are
familiar with onstar by gm
we have navigation systems driver
information systems to tell the driver
how to go from point to point in an
emergency to get service to the driver
but the most promising potential
is the ability to better manage the
entire transportation system
to be able to optimize traffic signals
to control ramp access
to spot accidents when they occur that
block lanes and remove those vehicles
to show
boards where you can say which parking
lots still have space available for
drivers for people waiting at bus stops
to say when the next bus is going to
arrive
so what we are creating is an
information infrastructure to manage and
control the physical infrastructure
the highway system of the 21st century
will be built around these concepts of
of pricing and the use of information
and control technology and its
we'll have congestion pricing to control
congestion primarily in the downtown
areas and other congested highways
we will have variable pricing on hot
lanes to offer congestion free travel
for a fee and this will all be under
intelligent transportation systems to
manage and control the network
so what we will see is a dynamic
responsive transportation system that is
adaptable to changing traffic conditions
and provides choice to the driver as to
what they want to do
now
there was limited time and i was going
to go into another innovation i'm going
to mention it briefly i'm going to
mention it briefly because it was
started by mit graduates
and this is the concept of car sharing
and here and this is intended for people
who live in the metropolitan area have
only occasional use for a car and they
don't really want to buy a car because
of the difficulty
of parking and the cost of maintaining
that car
zipcar started four years ago it has
1600 members and there are 145 cars
strategically parked around
boston cambridge and somerville in fact
there's a zip car in the kresge parking
lot right here okay
twelve percent of the members who've
joined zipcar have sold the car upon
joining 25 to 35 percent have avoided
purchasing a car
eight so eighty percent of the zipcar
subscribers don't own a car
95 percent of them don't use a car to
get to work when it's most difficult to
use a car
the estimate is that each zip car has
replaced seven to ten cars
and that zipcar has taken 15 cars off
the street
you know how severe the parking
situation is in boston taking 1500 cars
off the street is is non-trivial so
here's an example of how you're trying
to provide choice
to urban residents and how you're trying
to make the automobile more harmonious
with the urban environment
i've talked about the automotive system
as a very complicated system i'd like to
spend just uh
a moment in concluding talking about the
implications of this for for mit
it it's a system it's a large-scale
system
which
is
characteristic of lots of other
large-scale systems that we find in the
world today which are increasingly
dependent on technology energy systems
communication systems
the internet they're large scale
networks
and
they are expanding in size and scope and
complexity
we need engineers who understand
technology to design those systems
but those engineers need to know more
than just the technology they have to
understand organizational issues
they have to understand issues of the
context the impact the social political
institutional factors
so what we need really is a different
new type of engineer
that works with the traditional
engineering scientist the technical
specialist an engineer who has a broad
understanding of how to design
large-scale complex systems
and as usual mit is in the forefront
five years ago
mit established the engineering systems
division in school of engineering
but although it's in the school of
engineering it is a cross-cutting unit
which has
faculty coming not only from the
engineering departments but from the
sloan school and the humanities
departments as well
the faculty in esd has part of their
appointment in esd and then the other
part of their appointment in one of
these units so it's an organization with
porous boundaries it's an
interdisciplinary unit focusing on the
creation of large-scale complex systems
there are two objectives to esd
broadening engineering education and
practice and developing a new field of
study
in much the way mit after world war ii
revolutionized engineering education and
practice by introducing the concept of
engineering science
so too we believe a similar sort
of impact is going to happen with regard
to engineering systems doesn't mean
engineering science is less important
but we need both and mit is taking the
lead role
so in conclusion let me just summarize
what what i've described
is some really fundamental change some
fundamental change with respect to how
we might produce cars fundamental change
in where cars are going to be sold
fundamental change in terms of the way
our transportation networks are going to
operate
what i haven't talked about is some of
the really important
harmful side effects of automotive use
in particular the issues of energy
utilization and the issues of
environmental impact
and i haven't talked about them because
of their importance and because they're
so important we're going to have several
speakers who focus specifically on those
issues to see if we are on the verge of
the need for fundamental change so far
the car has been a reasonably adaptable
technology
that has been able to respond to
different regulatory
needs in terms of air pollution global
warming safety etc
so it's my pleasure at this time to
introduce our next speaker
john haywood who is director of the
center for 21st century energy and the
director of the sloan automotive
laboratory let's welcome john hayward
thank you
uh
let me follow dan by by saying something
about our
options
as we look into the future
i will look at the the technology
that we've got
on the development that we could put
into our vehicles not in a strict
engineering sense but much more you know
what are the possibilities a robust view
of the possibilities
and look particularly at the potential
uh impacts that these might have
let me make a few observations to set
the context the basic problem is
too many of us
use too much stuff
too often
and it's really important to remember
that there are these three components
of the consumption problems that go with
our transportation system
and the challenge is that they're all
growing
all three of them there's more of us we
drive more
and we use even more stuff so it's
getting worse and worse and worse
and as we look ahead we've got a series
of problems that i'm going to say a bit
about
now at the same time we have a very
effective
transportation system
it's a vital part of our economy it's a
vital part of our culture
it's been there it's been evolving for
decades and decades so of course it's
very effective
and i drove from my house in newton
to here door-to-door eight or nine miles
15 minutes this morning that's pretty
effective now you say was early saturday
morning yes
and of course the problem with our
transportation system is really we'd
love to have the same system but only
two-thirds of the number of people using
it but that's not possible
now most of the environmental
problems that transportation contributes
to they're getting worse
one or two we're making progress but
i'll talk a bit about
the broader scope in just a minute
it's particularly true that they're
getting worse
fast
and in a very problematic way in the
developing world
where there's neither the sort of
organizational infrastructure nor the
the economic wealth to deal with these
problems effectively and why this is a
problem is that
our system is so vast
that changing its impacts
take a very long time
now what are these impacts well here's a
list
the ones i'm going to talk about in more
detail are the top two petroleum
consumption and the greenhouse gas
emissions the carbon dioxide that
results from that and that's very
appropriate it's perhaps our biggest
short medium-term problem long-term too
but 2 plus a gallon gasoline is
underlining that forest
but you run your eye down that list
in the developed world we're making
progress on air pollution and it's very
high on people's priority list i think
the health impact is clear and that's
the reason we're keeping some things at
bay noise safety is improving at least
in the developed world it's going
definitely in the other direction in our
developing countries
the one that doesn't get much attention
is the the steady degradation of our
ecosystems that comes from both the the
road structure the facilities that
relate to transportation and the vehicle
impacts themselves air pollution water
pollution etc interestingly a national
academy panel that i served on a few
years ago looked at all of these
and and picked out the ones they thought
were
most important in a longer term sense
and then when that was number two
climate change
and the last one
biodiversity as a consequence of
ecosystem degradation so there are lots
of problems and and they result from
this too many of us too much stuff too
often
now i'm going to focus on the top two
and here at mit
i've been involved with colleagues in a
number of studies in our lab for energy
in the environment which is the unit
where much of the
sustainability issues energy and
environmental issues are being worked on
by multi-disciplinary groups and i put
the names up here
for a special reason we've had some
extraordinarily talented graduate
students work with this in these
problems
very able
and very idealistic young men if you
find felix o'young's name is in the top
there he came at my arrived on my
doorstep and i took him on for the
project and he proved an inspiration
he kept us older types young
and we taught him how to do robust
engineering it was a very good
combination and then he went off to try
and save china which he found
discouraging but he's still just as
idealistic as ever
now let me comment a bit on the
technologies enough to give you some
sense of what our options are
mainstream technologies gasoline engines
transmissions
vehicle components they get better all
the time some studies we've done show
that typically engines get better about
one percent a year
well not much you say but over 25 years
that's a lot of improvement the only
trouble is what we've done the last 20
years is we've traded increased
efficiency
in all of our vehicles we've moved up in
size and weight and we've demanded
higher performance so we've eaten up all
those gains in efficiency
there are lots of options
some details some
bigger changes that are
being developed some are coming into
production
a lot of promise we can make our
technologies better but there's a cost
it costs a bit more and the demand for
fuel economy is low
dan mentioned hybrids i'm sure you've
read about hybrids this combination of
an internal combustion engine with a
battery an electric motor sometimes you
use both sometimes one sometimes the
other they look very promising in terms
of a fuel economy
perspective toyota's doing very well
marketing its prius honda's following
interest in hybrids is rapidly rising
they really look like a robust technical
solution but
they cost a couple of thousand bucks
more
and we've still even at two dollars got
cheap gasoline
diesels are going like gangbusters in
europe uh in many countries fifty
percent of the new car sales uh have uh
half diesel half of them are diesels
half of them are gasoline engines one
reason is is driven by differential
taxes all fuels are expensive but
diesel's less expensive
the problem in the u.s is a business
case can you make a business case when
we don't know if these diesels will meet
the very strict emission standards that
california and the rest of the nation
have coming up in a few years
we don't know whether diesels will make
it big we don't know whether hybrids
will make it big but they're good
opportunities
on the more radical end of course
there's hydrogen and the technology that
would use hydrogen fuel cells
growing
research activities here at mit
in these areas i'm involved and many
others are
potential
yes
maybe this is what we have to do to get
the carbon out of our transportation
fuels but as i list here it ain't going
to be cheap
and the technology isn't yet that ready
and let me illustrate that
by
looking at well how do these changes in
technology have impact
and then on what time scale might we
expect improvements in what i call
mainstream technology and some of these
really radical new ideas
help us solve these problems and i'm
going to show you a graph which we've
produced that looks at you put these new
technologies you sell these new vehicles
they go into the fleet they're used by
you and me
what's the cumulative impact
over time
now we understand our fleet there's a
something like a 130
130 million excuse me vehicles out there
in the united states driving around we
add
15 million or so trucks light trucks and
cars each year
the fleet's growing we drive ever more
miles etc etc etc all that's well
understood and we can describe that
and here's a graph that i'll spend just
a minute on
it looks at the
united states
billions of liters per year i have no
idea what a billion liters per year is i
you probably don't either but it's an
unbelievably large amount of gasoline
and then here we go 1970 at this end of
the graph out to 2035
i'm willing to go 30 years into the
future i have trouble going further and
obviously this is history we're right
we're right about 2004 now uh you can
see things have been growing quite fast
and the top curve this dark blue one is
no change we keep doing what we're doing
now technology gets better
but we demand bigger heavier vehicles
and
better performance so we use it up
this curve
is what we think we might achieve if we
start to take doing something seriously
and then if we bring hybrids in so that
by 2035
half the new
vehicle sales are hybrids we can turn
this curve down
now you're probably looking at that
saying boy you're not making much
difference that's the nature of the
problem
cars last on average 15 years it takes a
long time to get new technology better
technology out there to have a major
impact the bottom curve is if we
stop fleet growth and stop driving a
little more per car each year
and those are only fractional percentage
changes but they compound over 30 years
in extraordinarily powerful ways you
know that when you buy a mortgage
you know that modest changes in interest
rate are going to have a big impact on
your monthly payments
now what this says is with this
technology turning this curve around and
bringing it down is not going to be easy
and remember that the kyoto a treaty
that we have not in this country uh
signed on to said we've got to get down
five percent or six percent below this
number
we ain't gonna make it this is our
opportunity space if we do everything we
can possibly think of we get to the
bottom curve but that's a bit too
optimistic uh human beings don't like
spending extra money to constrain what
they do so that we improve the total uh
impact situation
now just a couple of minutes on this why
does it take so long to have impact and
what i've got here is a table where i've
laid out the different stages
i've got an exciting new technology
i want to get it into vehicles
and have it have impact
first of all it's got to be competitive
so it's got to develop to the point
where it's market competitive and that's
the first stage and what i've shown here
is
diesels for the united states with good
emission controls we're about a
generation three years or so away from
having competitive technology we can do
it but it's too expensive
here's an advanced gasoline engine uh
highly turbocharged to follow the diesel
path and make the engine significantly
more efficient again a generation
roughly three or four years away from
being competitive
the next stage is okay priuses are out
in production these new hybrids
but by the end of this year there'll be
a total of a hundred odd thousand out
there in use worldwide
that's a small number
there's no impact until we're producing
them in the many millions how long does
that take to penetrate
across new vehicle production we've got
very little case history
to use to work that out but typically
it's at the best it's going to be 10
years
our estimate for fuel cells
is something like 25 years once fuel
cells are competitive this is stage 2.
and the third stage is you've got to get
a big number out there in use if you're
going to impact
our energy and greenhouse gas situation
so major fleet penetration today cars
last about 15 years so 10 years to get a
sizable number out there probably much
longer
if we've got to get the hydrogen out
there too so you add all that up and you
take a bit off because they overlap so
20 years for these relatively
mainstream technology evolutions it's 20
to 30 years
i get told off by two groups on this
column on the right some people say i'm
far too
optimistic
some people say i'm
much too pessimistic so obviously i'm
about right
my final point is if we are going to do
something about it we've got to raise
the importance of fuel consumption in
the marketplace and i've had another
very talented graduate student working
with me uh an up band of alika
on a series of policy measures that
reinforce we've tried to get stricter
fuel economy standards through congress
doesn't work we've tried to raise the
gasoline tax
doesn't work let's put all these things
together
so that they they add
there are synergies
and if we've got a diverse set of
measures the political opposition at a
minimum gets diffused
so our strategy is to look at a series
of measures and here's an example we've
completed some studies that look at what
the impact of this is likely to be
and as you like glance through it we're
going to make the cafe corporate average
fuel economy this is the united states
set of regulations that makes the
manufacturers meet these average
miles per gallon for their vehicles so
we're quite aggressive
but other people in congress have
proposed this in the past few years
a few years and the votes are growing
we can reinforce that with something we
call fee baits if you buy a really big
heavy vehicle that consumes a lot you'll
pay an extra few thousand dollars
as an additional fee
and that will get recycled to those who
buy at the other end a very efficient
vehicle they'll get
a rebate
and
the rebates
the way it works out the rebates are
several hundred dollars the fees could
be a thousand or two we've got a system
like this already gas guzzler taxes
they've driven gas guzzlers off the road
and then we couple this with raising
gasoline taxes five cents a gallon a
year
we don't want to shock the economy too
much
we have to
do things like this and then finally we
can push
the petroleum industry to increasingly
bring renewables into the fuel mix that
we use i was showing this the other day
to an industry group
and sometimes i get the reaction
this will never happen in the united
states
and an auto engineer from germany who's
involved in the environmental side came
up to me afterwards and says
we're doing all this already in germany
so when people tell me this is
impossible i can now say yeah well there
are many countries in europe where
they're already doing it
so what do we need to do
my group is taking this public we're
planning to put a workshop on down in
washington for congressional staff aides
that explain the realities here and get
them to take this problem seriously
but we're trying to find a good slogan
that will motivate the broader public
that that's you and me i'm a broader
public a person as well as an engineer
here at mit
what motivated me to find a slogan was
maureen dowd who writes these caustic
columns in the new york times
she ended one of them about our texas
oil men by saying
real men don't conserve
now negative slogans aren't a good idea
they've got to be positive so we're
working with drive light
it's got more in it than you might think
we need more efficient vehicles i've
talked about that
we need
lighter and smaller vehicles we can get
used to that and we will when we have to
but it ain't going to be that easy
we could moderate our driving with cheap
gasoline we don't have much incentive
that's why we've got to raise the price
of gasoline
and there are things that we don't
really want to talk about if we all
drove less aggressively we would use
significantly less fuel and you may well
want to add to this list so that's your
agenda
and mine as we go away from this
technology day focused on the automobile
but it ain't going to be easy and it's
going to take better technology
it's going to take smart regulations
that
create some synergies so we are
willing to share the responsibility of
doing something about this problem
and that's the change in attitudes that
we've got to find a way to
find inside ourselves so that all of
this can happen thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much john and dan for
those really stimulating uh discussions
i'm going to be a little brutal we have
10 minutes for questions because we're
going to face a hard stop with
connecting later on this morning with
the
international space station there are
two microphones
out here there are also some floating
mics
30 seconds no more to ask a question we
don't want speeches first question
that's 15 of the seconds
all right i'm sam losch i'm from the
west
and uh we don't want those small cars we
got
big cars
everybody's got a truck
and uh
we threw out governor davis
because he wanted to tax our big cars
and
i drive this little thing and i look up
at these big cars and i think gee i
better drive more defensively how big a
car can i get to drive defensively
enough
what are we going to do politically we
can't do that we can't get the little
cars
well i'm going to use the answer i just
gave there are
large countries in this world
that
have dealt with that
and they've obviously dealt with it
economically
in large measure
some of us have big houses we pay more
taxes on our houses some of us have
smaller houses we pay less taxes we've
got to mirror that
we'll get used to it because the thing
we will hang on to is our mobility
yeah let me let me just add
two things to that remember the 61 car i
showed you
we've come a long way from those sorts
of cars so people can change in terms of
what their preferences are at one point
in time we had to regulate auto safety
now auto safety is something that people
want to get so people's habits can
change over time
professor gray
my impression is that if hydrogen were
free
and
reasonably priced
fuel cell driven cars could be made
there still would be a problem in range
because the storage of hydrogen on board
is is limited is that the case john
yes
um
what i often say about hydrogen and i'm
working on it so don't think i'm against
this as an option
petroleum-based fuels are liquid gold
we have to recognize that
gaseous fuels and hydrogen is one
a much less convenient i've got lots of
problems of which paul just mentioned
one how do you store it how do you get
range
but
we may have to transition
away from carbon-based fuels and right
now hydrogen looks the best
of a not very attractive set of
alternatives
yellow shirt
i mean it seems to me that the fuel
efficiency and the gas tax are clearly
political problems today but we saw in
in this 73 under carter that that could
tip very rapidly when people stood
online for a few weeks we got fuel
efficiency standards through congress at
that time
so there may be some political tipping
point that makes it possible
and my question really is that if we got
to that point it seems to me that your
five cents a gallon per year is
incredibly modest in other words you
probably couldn't do that today at all
but when we get to being able to do
something wouldn't it be better to try
to do something that matters i mean i
would argue that half the dod budget is
already subsidizing
our gas prices and that would be 50
cents a liter right there
so the question really is if we got to
the point where we could do something
with a gas tax couldn't we do more
well i'll willingly raise it to 10 cents
a gallon but i i want to moderate the
shock as it were yeah
but let me say one one more thing what
concerns me
greatly about this
is as i showed the lead times for change
are very long
and we may well be facing on a
10 year or less time scale what i'll
call oil shocks
to our economy and other major economies
in the world driven by growth
in uh petroleum demand
we are not ready for that and we really
need to start thinking about getting
ready for that because we can't respond
in
six months
and have an impact
i think the important thing is to
establish the principle that the gas tax
can rise once you establish the
principle then you have the flexibility
over time to increase it from five cents
next brief question
kyoto is bunk
as another
fine product of the sloan
legacy
dick lindsen from the earth and
planetary sciences will tell you
if you want to save
on greenhouse gases stop watering your
lawn but my real question is if we're
serious about hydrogen
why haven't we mentioned the word
nuclear power anywhere
a question on climate change if you
if you want to pursue this something i
suggest is that the ipcc the
international panel on climate change a
year or so ago put out a summary report
where they took conclusions from all the
research work that had been done over
the past a decade or more
and they put it into a thick report
i have to say that when i read that
i had to admit
that
there's enough reality there we've got
to take this seriously
so uh
i think we do have to take this
seriously and i mentioned this national
academy committee study
climate change
and ecosystem degradation and
biodiversity loss were the two
major unsustainables that we thought
were there in the really long term that
we would have to find ways to deal with
ernie moniz is a speaker this afternoon
and he did a really path-breaking study
on nuclear with several others here at
mit so i think he would address that in
the afternoon session absolutely yes sir
i also live out in the west which is the
land of the large vehicle and i notice
in my daily driving that the percentage
of single occupancy ford expeditions and
chevy suburbans and those kinds of
vehicles
are it's phenomenal just an incredible
number of them and people claim that
they use them for
long trips the reality is they use them
to drive to work and
they're all quite expensive vehicles and
yet we seem unable to handle a two
variable problem which is that we're
trying to help people who are at the
lower end of the economy meet their
transportation needs and yet people are
at the higher end of the economy are
driving 30 to 50 to 80 000 vehicles
and yet not paying the carrying cost in
environmental terms how do we how would
we address that
well
we we ought to understand that
john mentioned before the corporate
average fuel economy standards and
that's a two-tier system
it made sense when it was set up when
these
vehicles were being used for off-road
operation the cafe standard for
trucks is much less than it is for
passenger cars and so the most important
thing to do
to change that situation
is to revisit the whole issue of cafe
and make sure that vehicles that are
really being used for passenger purposes
are subject to the same stringent
standards that passenger cars are can i
just add to that i often ask everybody
including myself
the average price of a new car is 18 to
19 000
and i i asked my audiences
put up your hand if you bought a new car
that was below the average cost
almost nobody puts up their hand because
we talk we talk
to high-end professionals
that's not the broader public let's
think about that i saw seven hands
[Laughter]
sometimes the problem is you keep uh
designing a small tank you know the same
group of people are uh
maybe it's time to call in the evolution
biologist because the fact is 98 of the
space and the mass
of the vehicles not needed the other
thing is you could have
an organelle system in which uh one part
inside travels on the inner city and the
rest stays in a parking lot and there is
interchangeability uh
for different situations a different
type of motor or something else could be
plugged in but these are probably uh
long way down the line
i think yes is the answer to that
the more better ideas the better we do
have some very innovative work going on
between folks in the media lab frank
gehry and other engineers here thinking
a bit about some really radical ideas
and transportation lists well we're
talking about transportation today and
the long term and i think what dan said
at the beginning about the engineering
systems division is that we need to
link
transportation to our
living and working infrastructure and
we've designed
our communities and our cities around
the car and cities in china are
reconfiguring themselves to accommodate
the automobile i think if we're looking
50 years out in the future besides
hydrogen and fuel cells we should look
at different ways of designing our urban
infrastructure and it sounds like your
program
may be a vehicle for doing that and i
was wondering if you would comment on
how you
fit that how you connect that through
your engineering systems division sure
well
in this case i'm going to
[Music]
think of another technology and and that
is
what the internet has done in terms of
how it's going to change our mobility
needs and and bear in mind that there's
a real link between mobility and
accessibility
and what the internet has allowed us to
do
is to work at home to shop at home
to do a lot of services in the past that
was going to require trip making
and that's not no law that's no longer
the case now you might say from that
well gee there'll be less trips then
that's not the case necessarily
when
the telephone was first introduced
people said well the impact of the
telephone is less travel
just the opposite happened the telephone
opened up new opportunities where people
got to know one another and there was
more travel
so i think what is going to happen
in terms of our mobility needs
is going to change rather dramatically
one thing that we should bear in mind is
telecommuting is really increasing and
for the first time people many people no
longer to
need to be physically close to their job
and so i mean this starts to get at what
you're saying you start to see people
changing their locational decisions and
also changing their mobility habits so
we we have to think
from that point of view not just supply
but how demand is going to change as
well we're going to take two more
questions if they're really brief yes
sir i'm surprised that you haven't said
anything to acknowledge the huge costs
and i mean money costs of a
transportation system that's almost
totally based on cars
we have the paradox here that even in a
rich place rich part of the country if
you suggest making a public
transportation system they say they
can't afford it
and yet figures i've seen say that in
places that have a complete public
transportation system
the
cost
is roughly half as a percent of national
income for transportation
could you comment on that yeah i think
you have to be very careful and and i
can't do justice to your question in a
very brief period of time other than to
say
that people
really misunderstand what the cost of
public transportation is and if one
looks at data
on a per capita basis particularly if
one is talking about rail rapid transit
it is a highly uneconomical system in
terms of building new rail rapid transit
systems
on the other hand there are some really
interesting ideas which started out in
south america and maybe ralph
geckenheimer will talk about them
of using bus platoons to serve almost
the same purpose as as rail rapid
transit does so
let me simply say that i think a lot of
the things that the press claims about
inequity between auto travel and public
transit is just not correct
last question from derry
hi i drive a battery electric vehicle
and
although the auto industry seems to have
completely written off that approach
it seems to me to have a lot of
advantages the only big disadvantages
that i can see being the high cost of
batteries when produced in the current
volume
and the severely limited range so if we
believe that there may be some changes
and attitudes about driving do you think
it's possible that that approach may
come back for the commuter car market or
is it does it have fundamental permanent
limitations
let me
i'm surprised that the the battery
industry
in a sense doesn't line up more strongly
behind what you've uh suggested
they're not very optimistic about
high energy storage battery battery
technology that's different from the
batteries that go into hybrids where you
want high power
but this range limitation means i think
that a battery electric vehicle
can't compete with a standard car
maybe there's a market for different
cars but to date that hasn't developed
so i think that's an open-ended question
but we certainly shouldn't take it off
our list of things that we investigate
mit does the impossible
and we are now going to achieve that by
actually having a 15 minute break
please we are going to reconvene at 20
till we are going to start at 20 till
there is an alternative which is to
stand up and stretch in place but we
have 15 minutes please thank john and
dan
[Applause]
so
we are about ready to reconvene if
everybody could please get to your seats
okay we are going to get started now
folks
our next speaker
our next speaker will be ralph
gackenheimer professor of urban planning
here at the institute ralph is going to
talk about the role of the automobile in
growing the economies of the third world
developing parts of our world
he will be followed by the last speaker
of the morning
and that will be joe coughlin who is the
director of the mit age lab
something we all have increasing
interest in
joe is going to comment on new
automobile technologies for the older
driver which he has termed driving miss
daisy digitally
and again as i said after we have heard
from ralph and joe we will have a few
minutes for question and answers and
then we will hook up with mike fink on
the international space station so ralph
please come up
[Applause]
good morning
it's a pleasure to have the opportunity
to share some ideas and hopefully propel
some debate and discussion for later on
going to talk about the part of the
world which is most impacted by
the
motor vehicle the developing world
and i'm going to talk in particular
about india and china why india and
china well you already know they amount
to
40 percent two thir uh two fifths of the
population of the world and a much much
higher proportion than that of the
potential increased motorization and
fleet growth in the world
uh you may have noticed in recent issues
of the london economist that china last
year
absorbed
forty to fully forty percent of the
entire world's production of cement
and accounted for ninety percent of the
increase of the demand for steel
my colleague
remi prodom at the university of paris
has concluded that the chinese are
building
as many lane
kilometers of highway each year as the
entire rest of the world is building
each year
shifting gears big time
and since this is uh primarily an urban
problem in many respects i'd like to
bring your attention to some figures
concerning the two
economic motors of these countries
mumbai former bombay and shanghai
they're cities of about the same size 17
18 million as
mega cities their growth rate is about
the same
rate although chinese figures are
difficult because they exclude the
floating populations call it three
percent a year roughly doubling the size
of the city every 24 years or so
level of motorization is 70 or 80 motor
vehicles per thousand that compares with
750 to 800 motor vehicles per thousand
population in the united states and more
than half of those so far as
two-wheelers because these are countries
where it all started with a bicycle and
they tend to ramp up through two-wheeled
motor
motor vehicles before reaching four
wheels
the rates of increase are staggering in
china 16 a year on recent average that
means that the fleet is doubling every
four and a half years imagine motor
vehicles doubling every four and a half
years
in uh
in india only seven uh or a percent a
year therefore doubling every ten years
the economies are growing healthily 6.5
the gnp in india but in china they've
recently moved up
from their usual eight percent a year of
growth in gnp and note that the
population's not rising fast up to about
9.5 and some observers say
that it may be as high as 13
a year and of course motorization and
fleet enlargement is very sensitive to
growth in the uh growth
in the gross national product the
purchasing power parity is quite decent
for the these are city uh figures now
not national
um are
is quite decent in both of these uh
cities the genie coefficient is a
measure of income inequality the maximum
is one and the higher the figure the
more unequal
and skewed the income distribution
0.7 is about as high as it gets in the
developing world so india has a very
skewed income distribution but a
substantial high income group who are
buying vehicles china has a much flatter
distribution because of the
regime but that's changing extremely
rapidly with the liberalization of the
economy and of course the greatest
change in income is in the upper income
part of the income distribution which
again indicates the prospect for buying
a lot more motor vehicles
one thing that takes you into a very
different culture is to notice the
densities of cities which are very
important to the transportation problem
250 to 255
people per hectare
in
in china and india
that's
as compared say with boston at around
12 or 13 people per hectare this is 20
times
the density it's about 100 people per
acre
and that's important to the
transportation situation the mud shares
are 65
in mumbai which is fairly typical for a
developing country but in
shanghai is considerably lower largely
because of the tradition of state-owned
enterprises which provide housing close
to work and facilitate the use of
bicycles and walk trips to a much
greater extent
the share of two and four wheeled
vehicles therefore is substantially
less two-wheeled motor vehicles that is
to say and for reasons just explained
the share of bicycle and walk trips are
considerably higher in china and has a
consequence on this low
transit level as a matter of fact now
that i think of it that transit share is
about the same as boston
the trip rate is uh modest but rapidly
growing that is the number of trips per
person per day this is the background of
what we're looking at these cities are
decentralizing from these very high
densities at an explosive rate it's
partly caused by motorization
growth of the automobile fleet but it's
also caused by other conditions and
policies of the government which would
be interesting discussion for a longer
presentation the fact is that they are
spilling out
over the countryside at a very uh rapid
rate and on the streets you see of
course uh the mix of vehicles that
represent the process of transition uh
that's going on in these countries uh
and in particular in china there's an
effort oftentimes to isolate different
kinds of vehicles into different lanes
so that their different operating
characteristics don't collide but
when you're
in the street it's a somewhat different
deal i'm about to tell you how to ride a
bicycle in shanghai when you're making a
left turn
this is only for the courageous listener
bicycles are on the outer lane on both
sides and motor vehicles are on the
inner lane in the same direction two
parallel lines each side so when you
reach the corner on your bicycle and
want to make a left turn you insinuate
your bike left in front of the phalanx
of oncoming motor vehicles
so that when the
light changes and the cross traffic
breaks you can dart across the place
diagonally in order to get your left
turn lane before these guys get a chance
to start and while your uh counterparts
on the other side are similarly keeping
the oncoming traffic there from starting
but of course the motor vehicles
eventually barge into this and the
result is mayhem if it was football you
could call it broken field running and
the consequence of this
is that
all over china municipal governments are
actively repressing the use of bicycles
and of course the environmental
community is up at arms how can you
possibly suppress the use of a vehicle
that's so environmentally friendly so
uh healthy so democratic and so flexible
um
and uh indeed it is democratic because
at the present time in china nationally
there is 1.8 bicycle per family and the
family is small so there's practically a
bicycle for every able person
and that's true across all eight octals
of the income distribution so it's a
very widespread and how can you suppress
a mood like this
well the cities are doing it to try to
handle situations of this sort and also
to
turn back the dilution of the market for
public transport which let's face it can
move people uh spatially speaking in a
more efficient manner
in india we have the same kinds of
problems especially involving the
participation of two two-stroke engines
this uh three-wheeled vehicle which is
very prominent in the traffic in india
pollutes a lot and makes an enormous
amount of noise and the buses of course
still have to access the sides of the
street in order to uh light and
take on passengers
and the problem of parking is absolutely
severe because there isn't enough around
so uh as here at connot place in delhi
there's parked cars everywhere and
leaving only a thin line for
the progress of cars around this
heavily used business center and the
general access to public transit is also
extremely
difficult even uh
for those who choose that
and the whole question of the density of
traffic is extremely uh problematic in
all over uh asia uh in india they're
fond of building these flyovers
overpasses but it's not clear to me or
lately even to them how effective that
is and even folks who are seeking
charity among the gridlock vehicles are
suffering also from the uh pollution
caused by these two-stroke engines which
are really a problem so
how can we structure this into some
sense of a set of challenges for policy
and planning in these countries first is
the question of congestion
the first problem indeed is to
understand the future of congestion as
you've noticed these cities are at least
as congested as american cities probably
more so on one tenth the number of motor
vehicles per uh per thousand inhabitants
how can that be possible well the answer
of course is that there are several
trans uh technologies transitioning
and they're all on the street at once
getting in each other's ways it's
difficult to reorganize trip itineraries
for people who
can't change as fast as the congested
conditions and the problem of overcoming
uh
uh land use patterns uh which uh no
longer serve the the current situation
are uh are difficult but the the point
that is important to understand here is
that
the level of congestion suffered by a
city
is not so much a function of the uh
number of motor vehicles per thousand
but rather the speed of change in that
figure it's the uh
it's the first derivative that's the
measure of the problem not the absolute
number and uh the issue is how much lag
and that's all a very interesting
discussion in any case for the time
being as you see all over the world trip
lengths are very long and
difficult problems are taking place
dan roose has given me a great start for
suggesting the ways of meeting this
challenge one is the role for car
sharing that was dan's zipcar
discussion and in the developing world
it may serve a somewhat different
purpose of permitting
the
use of an automobile from time to time
when necessary for people who could
never own one because they don't have
the money in the case of new electronics
there are just many roles in the
rationalization of traffic through
driver advisory systems which will
enable people to
for example
choose better times of the day to drive
to choose more appropriate destinations
to
choose more appropriate routes to make
to become aware of when and where they
can find a parking place and stuff like
that
and finally
the possibilities for
limitations of the use of automobiles
other vehicles in highly congested parts
of cities
this is already undertaken in a number
of cities for example santiago de chile
sao paulo bogota and mexico city in
latin america and others elsewhere
for purposes of environmental
improvement or or improved mobility and
i'm glad that dan brought up the
question of congestion pricing because
it looks like something whose time has
come
this is
for example i'm part of a project
sponsored by mario and luisa molina of
mit
where i
convened a group of transportation
officials from all over latin america in
mexico city recently and we discussed
possibilities that they were very
forthcoming about on congestion pricing
which is interesting and surprising
because it used to be anathema to even
speak of making a charge and
interestingly during about an hour they
discussed yes but how are we going to
sell it what are we going to call it
congestion pricing
value pricing like in america
hot lanes rationing
externalities control now you've got to
be an economist to believe in that
anyway the the whole thing is a matter
of how to position it because in the
developing world especially i believe
this is probably the only reasonable way
to make significant inroads on the
problem
the second problem of course is the
issue of public transport because it
accounts for 70 percent of the trips in
most developing cities and public
transport is an extremely precarious
mode with all kinds of political
problems and management problems and
financial problems that
are practically very difficult to
unravel and have given rise to the
appearance of a lot of unauthorized
transit in many cities
and
which makes the problem
uh further difficult the problems here
are how to create managerial strength
and sources of financing for public
transport
how to design and enact a more adequate
system integration i mean network
integration and fair integration maybe
management integration which uh is very
important and incidentally has been
accomplished more in the recent past
than it has during the earlier 30 years
or so we've been trying to do it
probably because computer programs which
can express
and adjust to different management
positions in the course of this
integration are now possible and
available
another possibility is to adopt uh new
modes for more rapid transit service and
uh dan also led me into that
it the move that's currently taking the
world by storm it's the great it's the
most explosive innovation in my lifetime
in public transport and possibly since
the invention of a streetcar in the late
19th century
this is bus rapid transit this is the uh
very successful
a very successful
system of bogota colombia called
transmilenio and here you have big buses
with very wide doors they're left
loading not right loading they have
independent of dedicated rights of way
and pre-payment stations and all kinds
of new electronics that expediate the
movement of passengers and of vehicles
and promise
to possibly keep the center cities alive
during a process of rising congestion
when they otherwise as has happened many
times before might become
economically depressed there's also a
system in quito in ecuador and the
original one in koretiba in
the state of paranat in southern brazil
they don't necessarily take up as much
space as it seems here in some cases
they travel also in mixed
traffic
the third point i'd like to make
concerns land use it's in a way the hard
part uh the explosive decentralization
of these cities has enabled people on a
higher standard of living to take more
advantage of all kinds of new
technologies they didn't have before
and it's certainly necessary these
cities are far too dense for modern
living but they have at the same time
created a number of important problems
social fragmentation the consumption of
more fuel more pollution the consumption
of agricultural land and so forth so the
uh challenges here
are to permit maybe even encourage
decentralization but at the same time
constrain it
so that it doesn't expand to the point
of absorbing too much natural resources
and also making the place extremely
difficult to serve by any kind of
of
structured transportation attention the
uh the idea would be to cluster demand
uh in the course of uh decentralization
as much as possible in order to be able
to handle transportation demand by
higher volume uh means
in the end of course what all of this is
about
is a need
for the developing countries to raise
the standards of living of their people
and so at the bottom of all of this is
mobilizing the labor market is reducing
cost of production reducing costs of
distribution improving the logistics
system
and recognizing the fact that in the
course of it
transportation infrastructure
investments generally have very high
rates of return
and
can improve the situation when properly
managed and that private capital is
increasingly interested in these
and uh again based i think on a lot of
lessons learned during the past years
and the use of computer models for
working out the distinctions of
obligations and
responsibilities of different
participating parties
makes possible a relatively intricate
public-private relationship to take
place and especially good assignment of
risk to take place and
therefore
some countries have are developing
transport systems which are highly
privatized
particularly
turkey
chile
colombia
mexico and a number of other countries
so this is uh
finally
it's important also to design these
solutions right because otherwise you
know by expanding the network without
relieving the throttles
you in effect worsen the condition
rather than improve it and that is
unfortunately what's going on in some
parts of the world so these are some
ideas i hope might be suitable for
discussion up here and down there as
time goes on and
i
look forward to that discussion thank
you very much for your attention and now
dr coughlin on
driving miss daisy digitally
yes i am the lucky guy who's standing
between you and the space station and
lunch
so
and i'm going to talk about you all
getting old so
that's a win-win situation i think
while we're setting up the technology
one of the things i wanted to to have
you think about is that as we think
about all the great achievements over
the past hundred years remember when we
were all worried about the 2000 turnover
and what i was going to do the computers
well we were also making long lists of
all the great technological achievements
many of them here at mit we spoke of
radar we spoke of internet we spoke a
middle
medical technology
we forgot one
not just space travel but we also forgot
about the fact that in 1900 life
expectancy was about 47.
today the fastest growing part of the
population is and by the way class
participation is 10 percent i will call
on you
fastest growing part of the population
85 plus
so life expectancy now is well into your
70s and probably you can expect even
better once you make that mark
but
with all that good news by the way i
have this up just so i make sure that
one other person has the same hairstyle
i do
so i'll give you the good news that um
our cartoon here can show you about 106
years to live for maybe some people in
the future
but that leaves us with a paradox
and as president vest was talking about
things that were uniquely mit i think
this is a unique challenge that mit
helped contribute to and now we are
uniquely charged to solve and here it is
now that you're living longer
what are you going to do
you know we rarely plan for success
we plan for public policy to have some
problems we plan for technology to be a
try and fail and try and succeed
solution
but we never really thought this
longevity thing was actually going to
work
so now that we're living longer we have
not even begun to think about where
you're going to live
what are you going to do and how are you
going to get around and so i want to
talk to you about the how we're going to
get around part however before i do that
the charge of the the age lab of which
on part that we're doing is basically
the charge that sarah knoss gave us and
she lived to 119 years old in fact if
she had lived a few more hours she would
have spanned three centuries she died in
december 31st imagine that 119 years but
she summed up i think one of the
greatest research challenges ahead of us
for the next hundred years
she enjoyed her longevity because she
had her health and she could do things
that's it
now that we're living longer we need to
find ways to help people maintain their
health and help them do things
and that leads us to transportation
because for all the talk about the car
and its problems and the light
it is the thing that most of us
particularly in north america rely on so
here's the class participation part
what is transportation i mean we're
talking about it we're spending the day
to it
i can wait by the way
ah spoken like a true civil engineer
point a to point b
um
yeah it is
that and it's a good way to model it
but think about it step out of your
academic your research perhaps many of
you engineering hats and realize it's
far more
that transportation really is the very
glue
that allows you to get from point a to
point b but more importantly to connect
all those little things that you take
for granted called life together going
to the cleaners visiting a grandchild
doing all those things that you really
take for granted so let me tell you some
of the people that we've done research
with about how they look at
transportation
and it is more than going from point a
to point b they identify it as freedom
independence and by the way not having
it as handicapped or disabled and by the
way transportation the united states
north america and as we heard from my
colleagues earlier increasingly around
the world is defined as
driving
and by the way the license is now being
called in the gerontology literature as
your personal asphalt identification
identicate whereas that license is no
longer just the thing that when you got
to be 16 it was your rite of passage
this is your sticker that you are still
independent and free to do as you will
so let's put the quotes to the people
we've done research with because we
learn a lot more from our subjects than
many cases
imagine the following survey done in
california a couple years back
top ten fears being diagnosed with a
fatal disease i would say that'd be up
there but think of this number two
losing the ability to drive which
interesting to my wife was above a
spouse being diagnosed with a fatal
disease
so
and speaking as a son it was also
interesting note that the financial
security of an adult child was after
that as well
responses from people we've talked to in
the lab on the other hand imagine and
this is where we think about the
problems with congestion pricing in the
future of the car this is where the car
politics really comes down one woman
told us that if she had to choose
between steak or eating soup every day
to have her car
she'd eat soup
now for you women this is the one that i
would be most worried about you can
always get another wife but you can only
get one driver's license
[Applause]
and so it really tells you what miss and
mr daisy mrs and mr daisy are thinking
but this is also the part of the dilemma
around the automobile that makes the
technology the politics also problematic
whether it's here in north america or
around the world this is not a
transportation question this is a social
emotional independence and freedom issue
so if you just think broadly the
population today is aging it's the
fastest growing part of the population
but it's a population that is more
education has greater health more income
by the way women are going to play a
greater role in fact there's some
studies out there that show that women
have contributed to congestion in many
ways and i'll talk about that perhaps a
little later at my own peril housing
patterns
contributing to our dilemma of needing
the car just very quickly the older
population today believe it or not
disability rates one could argue are at
least the static or on the decline the
bottom line is most people have at least
a chronic disease but they're managing
them well and they're continuing to want
to get out there we're having a longer
period of wellness if you will higher
education
more people with college education than
ever before more people using the
internet in fact one of the fastest
growing areas to retire in is not
florida arizona las vegas or even some
places like costa rica but near a
college campus to remain involved in
those activities of life learning and
productive productive living
larger incomes
most of the people at 20 of the
population are 50 plus they control the
majority of the income in the in the
country this is the same for most of
europe as well as japan the bottom line
is that think about the following if you
feel well
you have some disposable income and you
have education and this is probably not
a very nice thing to say at an alumni
event in particular but let's not
measure education in terms of how many
years you stayed in school but breadth
of interest so if you've got all those
things you're going to want to get out
you're going to want to do something but
there's something that we've never
thought about in transportation before
that's just happened in the last 20 or
30 years and that is
aging in place is now taking place
around the american dream 50-60 years
ago the idea was to move to levittown
move to those towns that were outside
the city beyond the reach of trans
public transportation well now what
we're seeing are people are now aging in
those places in many cases isolation
where frankly even if you could walk two
miles going to cvs on a friday night is
not exactly a trip out
so
public transportation it may be a good
idea but 70 of us in the united states
live beyond where transit serves or
where it serves well and by the way
think about the following public
transportation is very good for people
who've used it all their lives but most
americans have not used it all their
lives and if you don't feel well enough
to drive are you going to wake up one
day when you're say 76 and say you know
i'll take the bus
it's not going to happen
and this is where i get to blame my wife
and her associates um
basically the next generation of women
are not going to be like their mothers
women today have more education than men
in many areas they have greater incomes
than they've ever had before and by the
way they are the primary purchasers of
new cars on the markets today bottom
line is they're going to be driving a
lot more and even if you look at the
data today women do not drive more miles
than men but they make more trips which
is also the other problem around public
transportation it's not a point a to
point b algorithm it's a matter of going
from the cleaners to the daycare to
grandchild visit uncle joe whoever it
might be
so you put all these things together
and all of a sudden you start to see
that the population that is aging where
we once defined aging as retiring
staying home golfing whatever it is is
going to at least drive probably more
miles than what we see today and i find
it funny that the us department of
transportation where these data are from
are suggesting that my wife and others
are going to drive about the same as
their mothers and i don't think that's
nearly going to be the case so there's a
demand out there for transportation but
there's also a problem
the first chart on your left is what we
euphemistically call as a bathtub chart
and what this is the fatality rates by
age group now what the media like to do
is they like to look at that
particularly when there's a tragic
accident like santa monica a year ago
with the fellow who killed a number of
people in
a farmer's market they like to look at
that and they say oh my god people over
75 and kids between 16 and 24 get them
off the road
well i look at this chart another way as
we all know that lies and statistics are
not very far apart the first one is 15
to 24 is proof that octane testosterone
and alcohol don't mix
65 plus fatality rate is also proof that
the engineers of today in the auto
industry are designing the car for
essentially well a little younger than
me now at 5 foot 10 on a good day 165
pound male and if you're smaller frailer
suffering from osteoporosis and sitting
on top of that wheel you will die and so
this is a public policy as well as an
engineering challenge the same data i
showed you before in terms of the demand
for cars and driving in the future
indicate that if we have the car
designed the way it is today
and continue to have people trained to
drive the way they are today that the
number of older adults that will die on
american highways will be exactly the
same that we can attribute to alcohol
related deaths 20 000 people on the road
that is 20 000 elderly people on the
road also unfortunately whereas traffic
safety has improved for much of the
population the older population has
decreased so really we're looking at an
issue of cars not being designed for
older adults who want to drive more
cars that are not going to be suitable
for women in general and also a desire
frankly to get those numbers down for
safety so that we can continue to
participate fully in life
that said though one of the things we
should think about and this lady is 96
years old we interviewed her in florida
she has herself tested every year
voluntarily she drives a very large
cadillac i went for a ride with her it
was an interesting experience she did a
good job a little slower than a boston
driver and ralph i got very confused
those pictures look like they were
boston traffic cutting people off that
way
self-regulation this is how we mo how we
govern mobility in the united states
that is older adults essentially take
themselves off the road when they don't
feel comfortable nighttime bad weather
high traffic whatever it might be and
that's one of the ways that they keep
themselves very safe and perhaps the
rest of us very safe but also think
about the fact they're taking they're
denying travel when you don't go out
you're denying part of your life you're
not going out to the show at night
you're not going out to eat you're not
visiting a grandchild whatever it might
be but that is the primary policy if you
will of the united states
so let me introduce you to the older
driver and before we go much further we
are talking about older and older driver
what is an older driver give me a number
careful
see
no aging gets close real soon doesn't it
yeah
someone give me this
older than i am is usually a good answer
yeah
by the way the typical answer if you
want to quantify this is 15 years older
than the respondent
but let me tell you about the older
driver by the way the older driver from
an automobile standpoint is in your late
30s
because i can tell you that you need 20
times more light to see at night by age
40 to see as well as you did at age 20.
so any questions about talking about
older drivers are getting pop off the
road may want to start a lot sooner than
we think
but maybe not justified so let's talk
about reduced vision
reduced at 40. by the way 90 of us are
wearing bifocals by age 50.
state of arizona has decided that aging
begins at age 50 and started to regulate
older drivers at that age if you look at
the picture on the right this is what
your typical 20 year old sees in a
nighttime situation versus a nighttime
driving for a typical 60 year old also
macular degeneration is an increasing
problem amongst older adults whether
it's wet or dry macular degeneration and
that's what what starts to happen is
that you lose your center vision but as
we age all of us
start to lose our useful field of view
so things start to close in like this
and you may start to have a problem in
between
making it very difficult for that
occasional bicycle or whatever it is
that may dart out
improv impaired hearing isn't this the
cheery part of the conversation impaired
hearing by fifty percent of us most of
our student pair with some degree of
hearing loss
men in particular have a real problem
it's not that we're not listening to our
wives we often can't hear
and
as we talk about the smarter car
one of the things that a lot of us want
to do is we want the talking card
remember nissan when they came out with
the door is a jar
well very quickly we were looking for
the fuse box underneath well for men it
was very difficult because they had put
a woman's voice in there higher pitch
we really couldn't honest we couldn't
hear it and it was dropping out so as we
start to get older we have more
difficult time hearing these things and
it makes it very difficult to make the
car more helpful in that way
decreased strength and flexibility truly
if you don't stay in shape and fit it
becomes more difficult to turn that
trunk left hand turns the number one
accident that an older adult has is
making a left hand turn at an
intersection in part it's because it's
hard to turn that neck all the way they
did look but as we age we start to
compensate and forget that we're not
turning all the way to look we're not
using the mirrors as much
in addition that reduced strength makes
the fact that that airbag by the way
which was credited with killing a number
of small children a number of years ago
one of the things that did not come out
in the media is that the second part of
the population that had the highest
fatality rate were older women sitting
on top of the wheel so as they had
osteoporotic frames and the like when
that airbag came out that reduced
strength and flexibility to get out of
the way or move ended up killing and
injuring them
well attention and perception this is
the part that most have not focused on
with the automobile and that is is that
as we age our ability to maintain or
manage if you will the cognitive load
the things going on outside the noisy
kids in the back perhaps the radio the
cell phone the other issue is let's go
back to that left-hand turn believe it
or not there is some data out there to
suggest that men and women do drive
differently and they can make a lot of
jokes around that um
there is no scientific evidence about
men not being able to use map just the
willingness to uh to use them is in
question but for instance at that
left-hand turn men have a very good
shot at judging speed far better than
women do
on the other hand women seem to have a
far better idea at the distance
either way with that left-hand turn both
are at a deficit and often what you'll
see is people what we call co-piloting
one's driving the other one's advising
and in some cases that's a
it's a coping strategy that i'm not sure
i would advocate
so what do we let's talk about what can
technology do i mean after all we always
looked at technology as the silver
bullet there is in part of western
political culture the belief that
technology is going to solve it we just
have to work hard at it and work around
it well this is the third age driving
suit that ford developed a number of
years ago to take the average 27 year
old engineer and to give them the cheery
feelings of neuropathy in their feet
reduced haptic strength and flexibility
in their hands vision and said okay now
drive
what the car companies are looking at
now is the convergence if you will of
multiple information technologies
intelligent transportation systems such
as dan roos was speaking about earlier
bringing more intelligence to the car
enabling for instance the night vision
some of you may have this in some of
your vehicles enabling you to see in
poor weather or at night time things
that you would have a more difficult
time to see collision warning systems
again with the voice telling you that
you're either getting too close or
someone is getting too close to you the
difficulty is
as your bandwidth between the ears
begins to reduce
the car companies and engineering
innovations out there are asking us to
bring more and more into the car so
here's the challenge ahead of us
is is it possible in some cases that
technology can be too much of a good
thing and it's toyota put here if you
can see the the advertisement there says
engineers tend to get bored making cup
holders well the idea here now is we're
trying to put as much gadgetry in the
car navigation systems collision warning
systems uh very soon you're going to be
driving by your local shopping mall
they're going to have the zip code your
cars registered in the driver's license
whether you're male or female and your
relative age and lo and behold you're
going to get an advertisement in your
car from
brooks brothers and tail or whoever you
think it might be
well the problem now is how do you
design all these things that may very
well be innovative and be able to manage
the very challenges that older drivers
present to the engineering community
into the car companies because here's
the here's the the paradox these
innovations are not going to go into the
ford focus they're going to go into the
high-end platforms the lexus the
cadillac the buick who buys those
the 50-plus so the very first guinea
pigs for the new technology are those
who have got developed a 40 or 50-year
mental model of how to drive the old way
so let's talk about the real estate and
design issue this is a 2001 and a 2002
taurus dashboard same equipment package
one of the things that you find out with
older drivers and younger drivers have a
bit of this difficulty as well but as we
age and our vision becomes more
difficult we have a different uh timing
on how to find something on the
dashboard it's called target time so
where's the knob
find it turn it go back to the driving
task same equipment package on this dash
however the car companies were actually
afforded in this case was having a
challenge of do you spread it out
which means while you're driving you're
trying to look and scan or do you put it
in one place which means you're trying
to look and sort it out and so there's
really no quick solution on what that
ideal design should be
data fusion or confusion as we bring
more and more things into the car are we
actually
challenging that perception problem that
older adults have and in some cases
younger adults you know younger adults
and some of the research we've done with
warning systems for instance in the
vehicle do not have a advantage over
older people using technology in the car
older adults have something that none of
us have until we get to be older
experience
they have judgment
well there's a problem with the
technology it's not that they don't want
the technologies that when a warning
goes off we have found that older people
want to like pause and look around i
didn't see why the warning went off why
did it go off younger people on the
other hand have such a belief in the
technology that when it goes off that's
the only time they look or they don't
look at all they wait until the warning
goes off so if one day that technology
doesn't work and i know that all of you
believe that it's always 100 effective
you could have a toddler or a trike
behind the car and people were now
finding in our simulation as well as
on-road tests that are stopping and not
looking any longer versus the older
drivers are being distracted by looking
for that technology as to why it's gone
off at all
so do we design an old man's car
absolutely not as the adage of the auto
industry goes you don't design an old
man's car because a young man won't buy
it but frankly neither will a young man
or an old man as well so what we're
doing at the lab and this is miss daisy
it's a volkswagen bug basically there
were three reasons why we had it one was
relatively small until we got it in the
room and as you know parking mit is a
problem and this continues
continues the tradition of putting cards
in strange places at the institute
um one it was relatively small two
better yet it was free and three could
you think of a car that was more
symbolic of the aging baby boom
population so this is our platform
trying to better understand the ultimate
design of technology and the older
driver to do something that we really
need to do get around i don't care
whether it's car by foot probably public
transportation but you're not living
until you can visit all those little
activities that you call life and hope
to translate that longer life and
driving to look something like this
thank you very much
[Applause]
joe if you and ralph will please come
over to the side of the stage thank you
for those wonderful presentations i was
reminded of an interview i read about a
few years ago when this remarkable
older woman in france who was way over
100 who remembered vincent van gogh as
young girl and so forth was asked by a
reporter
what do you think about the future and
her answer was
it will be short
so we're going in the same format we've
got about 10 or 12 minutes for questions
those of you have questions please get
behind the mics keep them to 30 seconds
and let's keep on that track sir
ignoring the issues of
wildly overcrowding of the roads that
india and china look like they have
already not
even moving to the future what's your
projected impact on
oil
consumption in the world i mean the
saudis have come up with two extra
million barrels a day just to keep our
prices down a little bit what's going to
happen when china triples their
consumption and india does the same
all of it's going to be
imported um i really don't have a
commentary on that question i work
mostly at the urban level and there are
people here particularly ernie muniz who
probably would have a better answer for
that than i would so i'm going to defer
yes
hi i'm curious when automobile driving
will really become automatic uh in in
the sense that we'll be able to sit back
and read a newspaper and really let the
technology completely take over and take
us from point a to point b
um i don't know if you saw it it just
came out this week bob lutz was credited
design guru in the auto industry was
credited with making the commentary that
he sees it coming very soon and he has
declared driving is dead
which was very interesting because he
didn't have that position a few years
ago when he took the job
the problem i see is that whether it's
the older population the younger
population one of the things that we
forget about is that often driving is
for enjoyment
and even if we can move beyond that
because driving is getting less and less
enjoyable with congestion and all the
things that go along with that it's not
just a matter of whether the car can
drive itself the infrastructure is that
other part of the equation and we may be
able to do it for interstates we may be
able to do it for memorial drive but the
places we go to tend to be so intricate
of a pattern that it's probably going to
take a number of decades similar to what
it took to create the american dream in
suburbia to make that happen
yes sir thank you very much as one who
who thought it was a good idea to
require a driver's test when you're 75
and then was pretty much insulted when i
had to take it
i asked a question what do you see out
there now
available or is there anything
in the if i'm going to be buying a new
car in a year or two
what should what can i look for now that
is focused on some of this or do you
think that it's going to be off three or
four years before we have some of these
devices and things you're talking about
even if it is a high-end car
a lot of a lot of the technologies are
out there the collision warning systems
and like uh extended mirrors the problem
is is that as consumers we have to do
our research despite the fact that
50-plus population has the majority of
disposable income the auto industry
loathes to talk to us and so the bottom
line is you're gonna have to do your own
homework to find out what's out there
and more importantly you're going to
have to teach yourself or find a driver
education school to teach you how to use
those devices and those technologies
because the dealers just simply don't
know how to do it
this relates to
urban engineering
isn't it true that the largest waste
underlying waste
of fuel it comes from stopped and
stopping automobiles
and this is a measurable quantity
that's certainly the case yeah
and uh the the consequence is that
opportunities for uh making
traffic more
efficient
through something like congestion
pricing and uh
and by other means through uh driver
advisory electronics and so forth is uh
are possibilities
for ultimately saving some fuel
consumption
yes
well there was considerable discussion
this morning on
their more increasingly crowded driving
environments in developing countries
uh one solution that i didn't here
mentioned at all was population control
that is to limit population growth or
maybe even allow it to decrease and i
welcome your comments on that
these are
[Applause]
these ain't easy questions to answer
i
of course the chinese are very good at
population control
and
have restricted families to
uh to one child and this has resulted in
the fact of course that those
increases in gnp
in total gnp are very telling because
they're that gnp is not uh spread over a
large uh uh population but looking over
the uh
the whole city and of course the indian
family is not getting any uh smaller so
that uh
there there's a difference in the uh
future suggested by those considerations
there's a whole bunch of different sort
of uh third and fourth level issues here
one of them is the control of city size
which was once a popular uh concern but
generally speaking has dropped out in
favor of other things
the
overall concern for population control
the consequences
that aids will have on african
populations and the growth of
transportation problems in that region
is is also a subject worth
considering
and
it
nonetheless appears to be the case
that
large urban populations are present
population control in general doesn't
affect them very much because even in
places like china where the population
is not growing the cities are because of
a rural to urban movement that's bound
to continue and as the administration
becomes more uh
less forceful will be uh uh will be uh
further uh accelerated
uh so it's a
a situation where
the principal controls i believe
are primarily on getting a grip on the
land use
possibilities in order to
have a geometry that's easily uh served
by contemporary technologies on the one
hand and using uh techniques that
require more socially effective use of
automobiles such as congestion pricing
on the other and incidentally i don't
expect that to have any uh
consequence at all as often as sometimes
suggested on the reduction of the
purchase of motor vehicles in fact it
could even incentivate them because it
provides the possibility for using a car
under circumstances that if you're
willing to pay a small uh
congestion price
rather than being stuck in traffic all
the time
yes
there's certainly some opportunity for
removing some cars from the
road through
people having a rental car for a period
of time when they need to use it and
instead of having two cars
there's a
zip cars of course wouldn't it be good
public policy
to provide a lot of public education
on the options that are available
i think a lot of people would use more
options if they
were educated about them
both of us could answer attempt to
answer that education is certainly
extremely important and uh
concentrated efforts to educate people
are
in programs i could mention all over the
world trying to educate children to cope
with traffic better in order to avoid
accidents of children educating cyclists
in order to stop creating problems of
the sort i describe
educating motorists to take advantage of
driver advisory systems and
possibly
taking advantage of zipcar like systems
although they are not as easily adaptive
to america as they were to europe
because they basically assume a quite
substantial public transport system
useful for most of the trips of a person
who gives up his car
and it also has problems in the
developing world where there are a lot
of unlicensed drivers and other
complications
but certainly education is extremely
important the piece of work we're doing
that plays into that by the way is also
to what point or to what matters
transportation part of your retirement
planning we've defined retirement in
this country around your health
insurance and your 401k
well retiring someplace where there are
no alternatives other than the community
van
may make you essentially sentence you to
isolation in the very symbol of your
success your home that's several miles
from
anywhere bob
the obviously the capacity of the urban
highway system is is not adequate for
peak loads but is adequate for other
times a day and we heard more about the
hot lanes and these things what kind of
capacity increase is latent in the
system if we do a lot of electronic
information system kind of work as we
were hearing about and it strikes me as
it would be a lot cheaper per mile to do
that than to try to build another lane
of highways in cities
certainly a lot cheaper to do that
in the case of something like congestion
prices of course you can choose your own
number
and
the
level of traffic more or less
corresponds
inversely to the amount of the charge in
singapore for example they tried widely
different levels for a long period of
time until they basically fine-tuned the
situation to the level where in
singapore there is basically no
congestion at any time in the center of
the city
sounds like somebody disagrees maybe
it's changed since last i saw it
but in any case it's a whole different
scene i assure you than places where
there's no control so the the whole
question of um how much congestion can
be reduced is frankly in the hands
of the uh graduation of of leverage on
that and basically the limit is
political rather than anything else the
question is uh how much will will the uh
voter
uh tolerate an increased charge of using
congested street
to the
extent necessary to
make a significant gain on congestion
i very much appreciate you pointing out
that to an older person the ability to
move around is everything but i think
it's true of all age groups the car
appears to appeal to something visceral
in the human psyche no matter where
people are or how much money they have
and so it appears that in effect what
we're saying is engineers have overdone
the job we made the automobile too
attractive and so we're using it at a
rate which is not sustainable and
therefore we're trying to look we as
engineers we have no engineering
solution we're looking to the
politicians to bail us out by raising
taxes to make cars artificially
unattractive so people use them at a
sustainable rate
[Applause]
now that sounds everything you're saying
sounds like a confession of failure as a
technologist is that
and you're saying we're talking about
public policy here to get us out of a
situation that we engineers have created
for ourselves is that more or less
how you people interpret the situation
i don't know how to respond to that
question uh except that you simply you
pretty much have the equation right i
think but we're waiting for you to
suggest to the manufacturers to make uh
vehicles less attractive
well and the other part of that is the
science and engineering is never done
it's evolutionary so we just do the next
step
one last question well maybe uh part of
that can be answered by this question or
maybe it can't i don't know
but at any rate an automobile is two
things it's a
container
for you and your possessions and your
friends
and it's
a
piece of apparatus to move that
container
and
provide it with power to do so
and therefore
can we separate those two
maybe the container can be moved by
rubber tires maybe it can be moved by a
flatbed truck
maybe it can be moved by rail maybe it
can move by the water
there have been various
initiatives attempting to create
extremely high density guideways
which transfer the box to a train
train-like
function once it's on a uh
you know a main corridor and then
permitting it to return to independent
operation once it reaches its
destination
the
problems i think is are first it's not
clear how much that would actually
improve total capacity
uh but secondly that it would require a
difficult transition it couldn't be
transitioned incrementally it would
require the
public to buy large amounts of
automobiles capable of those two
bimodal performances all at once in
order to make the infrastructure
worthwhile in the space it occupies
worthwhile
you did so well we'll take one final
really quick question
the i i
this is for joe coughlin primarily the i
belong to that group that believes that
older drivers are about 15 years older
than me
um but i have to confess i have noticed
my diminishing acuity
and so i take it seriously you described
all the problems
that older drivers have behind the wheel
what would you say are the
two or three most promising developments
that are coming along that will make
that a lot better
probably
vision enhancement such as night vision
as one too because the number one thing
that older drivers complain about and
indeed have a difficult time with is
with night vision and contrast
sensitivity
secondly would be some of the collision
systems are coming out there to help
judge speed and distance although
there's a lot of bugs to be gotten out
of there i'm sure that the
legal community will make their fair
share of money on
those systems when they do not work
and then third they always look to
low-tech as being your first order of
defense one is really look for those
mirrors pedal extensions seat
adjustments that will make the car that
you live in today if you will safer so
you can move around tomorrow
next year
when someone else is president we are
going to have a session a technology day
on
congestion pricing for
for population control but in the
meantime please thank our speakers
we're good to go right now
i'm very pleased at this time to
introduce a very special guest
lieutenant colonel michael fink of the
united states air force
mike will be with us shortly through a
link from the international space
station
a member of the class of 1989
and while we regret
while we regret that he is not
physically here for the 15th reunion
events we are very fortunate that he
will be joining us virtually this
morning
at mit mike was an air force rotc hi
mike this is chuck vest down here on
earth
he holds a dual sb in aeronautics and
astronautics and earth atmospheric and
planetary sciences he went through the
russian program and spent a summer in
the aviation institute in must in moscow
he entered the air force after earning a
master's degree in aero astro at
stanford in 1990.
he was chosen by nasa to become an
astronaut in 1996
one of only 35 candidates selected from
two thousand four hundred applicants
he headed for his six-month mission on
the international space station in
mid-april
aboard a soyuz rocket launched from
kazakhstan
he spent four years in training with his
crewmate russian cosmonaut gennady
padalka excuse me
mike and commander padalka have had full
schedules while in space with a workload
just about the same as that of a normal
three-person team they will perform two
space walks over the summer as they
ready the space station to receive a
cargo ship from the european space
agency
mike welcome to your reunion
i wonder if you could just explain to us
a little bit of the goals of the
international space station
president vest thank you very much for a
signed introduction i'd like to check
our thumb can you hear me
you can we can hear you very well
when we were setting this up with nasa
they were wondering if we'd be able to
get a good audio and video and i can see
you guys great i'm glad you guys can
hear me and i said if anybody could uh
do great audio and video it's mit
thank you very much the international
space station is uh symbolic of what
human beings can do when we work
together constructively and not
destructively it's a great aerospace
engineering enterprise and it's also a
good place to do science
and i've personally been amazed the the
difference in
uh
fluids and other materials in free fall
or microgravity environment than than i
expected even though i had all the
physics background thanks to mit to
understand what was supposed to be going
on but it's absolutely amazing when
surface tension is much more
uh much more of a factor than say
gravity so there's so many interesting
things that we can do up here and
gennady and i are working hard to try to
succeed with the mission of the
international space station
and uh and you mentioned workload this
was this is nothing compared to what
unified was about
i understand colonel that one of the
experiments you're working on
involves tiny satellites developed by
the mit space systems laboratory could
you give us a little bit about that
absolutely
uh first off the
mit folks came in and uh like normal uh
regular mit folks they had all their
they had their act together they had a
really outstanding plan that you know
thought outside the box and i can say
that nasa needs more people
like that to work on on our programs
and such such payloads the mit spheres
program is absolutely amazing
it's pure three
body motion
dynamics control systems in action and
not only that it also offers
let me describe it first first these are
a series of of uh small spheres and
small being maybe the size of a soccer
ball or football
and uh and they're about around and and
they can float around and they have
active control systems and that's pretty
important my actual system isn't always
very good up here in space
even though i've been up here a month
and a half already and still have to
stay in those same spot
constantly but in addition not only are
they going to try to fly one little
sphere around but the sphere is in
formation
and this is all with an active
ultrasound control system that
ultrasound gives awareness of the
environment and these are the kinds of
things that we need help with and board
the space station especially if we only
have two people but even if we have six
or seven
these spheres can actually eventually
the same kind of control laws can really
help us uh for example even if we took
one of these outside we don't have the
ability to take a look at all of our uh
spacecraft with our cameras on board so
if we need to know what's going on on
the outside sometimes we have to send
out people and that takes a lot of
overhead but if we can send out a sphere
or even if it's you know a little bit of
artificial intelligence on it and say
hey go check out that port starboard
camera or go check to look at that
antenna for us that would be great help
for us so this is a very exciting
project and i'm glad to be part of it
thank you mike of course one of the
great things about the space station and
specifically about the work that you and
your russian colleague are doing at the
moment
is its international nature i wonder if
you could comment a little bit through
your experience on how the space station
has worked as an international
collaboration and what you see for the
future in that regard
that's a that's one of my favorite
talking points of all time and there's a
lot of things i want to say about that
but first i want to say is that mit set
me up very nicely in my career and in my
life
to be ready for this
next wave of globalization that we're
experiencing right now
this morning's program you guys uh
talked about the about the automobile
industry and i think we're talking about
that a little bit more this afternoon
uh the automobile industry was one of
the first
trendsetters for multinational
corporations multinational vote and
globalization
some of the to some people these are bad
things i think it's a really good thing
it really shows what we can do working
together
beyond our national borders
the international space station is a
symbol but it's also practical and well
let me tell you i uh when i got here in
1996 the experience i had with through
mit and the exchange program with moscow
aviation institute nasa snapped me right
up and threw me straight over to russia
and we started working
some of the issues of how to run an
international
space station beating parts and pieces
that were built in one country
first time that they ever met and worked
with the other parts like say two
modules was not on the ground which is
how we like to do things in the
aerospace business you know test test
test and then fly well we first time
a lot of these modules ever you know
worked with each other was up in space
and i used to think only in star trek
that things work right the first time
but with the space station it showed
that with careful organization and
planning we can really work we can make
these things work correctly and that the
human beings we really are starting to
understand our technology and that the
lessons that we've learned working
together with our russian partners with
our european partners and our japanese
partners can really set the stage for
expanding human presence in the skies
and on the way to the moon and to mars
thank you mike
the following question i don't mean at
all in a political sense but i think
it's really important
as you know the nation is about to
recommit itself to
the concept of space exploration with a
big emphasis on the word exploration
and that has triggered down here on
earth a lot of debate about the
relative merits of
human space flight for exploration and
robotic or technological space flight
for science
i will personally state that i believe
we need both and getting the balance
right is is very important i wonder if
you could share with us a little bit of
your observations on how the human and
robotic space programs balance
i together agree with you that we do
need both we can't do one without the
other uh there are some proponents of a
pure robotics way and this is an old
argument of course and our robot been
getting better and better and that's
really good that's going to be helpful
but we can't really do it they can't do
everything that human beings can do and
uh my commander and i are an example of
that we have a
power supply that controls one of our
control moment gyroscopes and uh it kind
of went out and uh right now robots
couldn't go out and fix it gennady and i
can and to give that extra capability to
the space station
so we need to have a balance of both and
as we explore
we really
we really need to have both for example
when we went to the moon
every place that we went was carefully
mapped out by robot explorers and there
are some mit grads over at the jet
propulsion laboratory who are exploring
mars ahead of time for the humans that
are about to come
and this is the strength of mit of
course they're working with
their teammates that come from other
universities too but we're here at the
forefront of it and some of us are from
the class of 89.
getting a lot of applause
colonel are there any other things that
you would like to say to those of us who
are gathered here
any messages that you would like to pass
along to your fellow mit alumni
i miss
mit
15 years ago and uh
everybody who was an alumnus in front of
me said you know it goes by fast and boy
it really does um and i'm sure i'll
probably feel that way after 20 and 25
years
but the the nice thing about having time
is it's given me a little bit of
perspective and
and the view we have on the planet uh
from up here gives me some more
perspective
and what mit does is very important
the mission of mit the way that mit
goes about teaching its students and the
way that mit is not afraid to be world
class these are very important things to
the entire planet
and so i'd like to suggest to the uh our
alumni and challenge the class of 1989
to contribute towards mit a little bit
more nobody paid me or asked me
[Applause]
a profession that paid more so that i
could give more but really this is uh
this is what we're doing is very
important at mit and it's important for
the entire planet i i truly sincerely
believe that
and i'd like to thank my classmates for
attending this reunion and and letting
me have some uh time here today and i'd
like to to thank uh
the people that put this
this this video conference together
because i really was sad i couldn't come
to this year's reunion
mike if you'll forgive me for making a
brief kind of personal comment i had the
great honor back in 1994 of serving for
a year as
chairman of the presidential committee
on the
redesign of the space station
and
that group among other things
worked together with nasa to make this a
truly international venture
and to change the orbital inclination so
that you would in fact be able to get
access from baikonur via the the soyuz
and i think my colleagues who came up
and worked on those ideas would
be as proud today as i am to have had a
little piece of this it's just a real
thrill to talk to you out there
we're very grateful and you stand as
just a remarkable role model for the
young men and women studying here at mit
to think about the potential that is out
there so if you have any last closing
comments
now's the time but we all then are going
to thank you enormously for
participating with us today
we have built a beautiful incredible
space station and uh i'd like to thank
you president vest for your work on the
space station
it really is really
an incredible piece of machinery
incredible piece of engineering a great
symbol for what human beings can do and
it's a great laboratory and we're
working hard aboard and on the ground to
realize the full potential of the space
station things are going slower than we
expected but that's the nature of
engineering that's the nature of
technology but we're not going to give
up and we're going to continue on with
the space station's mission
and
the young men and women of today have a
have a great potential future and
places like mit can really help them
realize that potential mit helped me
realize my potential and i'll forever be
grateful so thank you for letting me
hear in front of you today and it's a
real joy and pleasure and i just wish i
were there in person so president vest
thank you very much and
thanks to all the people that put this
conference together
[Applause]
well that
was one huge message to you
wishing you well thanking you for what
you're doing for the nation the world
and wishing you a safe journey home we
hope we'll see you here on campus next
year thank you
[Applause]
wow
can you imagine
i was asked if i could somersault onto
the stage since i needed to follow that
joe be thankful you don't need to follow
this
well we've got another first for tech
day here to uh to usher us into lunch
and this is a 15 second audience
participation segment
so all you folks on the left when i do
this you're going to go
shall we try it
yeah pretty good keep it short a little
more diaphragm not bad
you folks over here on my right you're
gonna go
pretty good all right
now that's an original composition i
call it a thousand freshman at a
flashing red light
thank you for holding your groans until
the end that's good yeah
so i'm keith mckay i'm the chair of the
tech day committee and i'm told we have
a record turnout here today
and we really want to thank you for that
those of you who are alumni know the
phrase ihtfp
many of you have stated this
some of you at the top of your lungs and
after i graduated i came up with my own
personal variant of this which is
institute has the finest people
and you know it's been exhibited this
morning by our panelists by beth garvin
by president chuck vest by colonel fink
and i really want to thank you all thank
you thank you thank you
thank you
it's also been exhibited by lou
alexander of the alumni office who was
the guide for our committee and who
really made all of this happen
and by my alumni colleagues on the
committee kimberlyanne francis mindy
garber kim hunter leon katz bill lach
eric peterson mary schaefer david stork
sarika vajala and doug vincent who will
serve as next year's chair it's been a
real pleasure to serve with you all and
you can see what kind of a group it
takes to make this all happen
if you know a committee member thank
them and then tell them how to top this
program next year
you know
if you don't know a committee member jot
your ideas on the survey and fill in the
rest while you're at it that's in your
packet as you might expect of an mit
group we do actually read the surveys
and use them as a feedback mechanism to
help improve the program but it's you
know it's a feedback mecha a feedback
system it's a collaborative system it
only works if you fill out the forms so
thank you for doing that
finally there are two housekeeping
announcements and a teaser for this
afternoon and i'll let you get to lunch
so the lunch is in the tent actually i'm
sorry it's in johnson athletic center
correct so round to the left building
over here you can't miss it lunch runs
from 12 30 to 2 p.m
number two we've been lucky enough to
get some vehicles from selectria and
from the mit solar powered car team
for our own mini car show outside so you
should enjoy those after stepping
outdoors
and
if you found this morning as fascinating
as i did you'll all want to return this
afternoon for more shifting gears we
don't have breakout lectures like we've
often had in the past but rather another
panel that we'll explore you know based
on some of the problems of this morning
where this is all going or where it
might go
now garrison keeler said that an
education is like four-wheel drive you
just get stuck in more remote places
and uh this afternoon our panelists will
help us to test that hypothesis you know
i guarantee you're all going to walk
away with some new ideas to explore and
uh join me here enjoy the car show on
your lunch and we'll see you back here
this afternoon
so
are you gonna go
good afternoon
that work
yay
i found out the role of the executive
vice president is just to test the sound
system that's the only reason i'm up
here
i was struck this morning when dary
cabsonell mentioned that he had an
electric car
my husband and i were some some of the
first lucky owners to get uh the first
prius when it ran up came out in the
united states and i just wondered if
there are other people here who are
driving hybrids or electric cars or
anything else perceived as an
alternative vehicle how many do we have
it is not an uncommon sight on the mit
campus to see a prius these days the the
lot i park in we're up to three and it's
a lot of about 30 cars um so i think we
are early adapters to these things and
i'm proud to be part of that
it's my pleasure to introduce our
afternoon moderator we're very
privileged to have norman augustine here
with us to play that role today as i
think almost all of you know he is the
retired chairman and ceo of lockheed
martin and has been not a stranger to
the mit campus as a former member of the
mit corporation
he will lead us through the afternoon
and without further ado norman
[Applause]
well i had no idea when chuck asked me
to do this and he was going to bring a
bunch of astronauts in as part of his
show
he's a tough person to follow
there was a engineer who was
streaking down the highway in his
brand new bright red hybrid vehicle
sports car
he looked at the rear view mirror and to
his utter amazement he saw this
three-legged chicken
racing and coming up right behind him
this chicken pasture went around him and
wind into a barn
so he stopped pulled off the road went
over by the barn where there was a
farmer he said to this farmer you know
that what that's amazing i thought i saw
a three-legged chicken
farmer said well you did you said we
like drumsticks around here
said we've been doing a lot of research
and development been pretty successful
the engineer said you know i'm astounded
he said how do they taste
the farmer says no no we never caught
one
now that's a pathetic way to introduce
the afternoon topic
i had to reach
but we've been doing a lot of research
and development we've gotten some very
high performance but almost no one has
caught one yet
and so we want to talk a little bit
about the prospects for new ideas
and the possibility that they will
become more commonly used
i
chuck gave his credentials as a car
owner as an aeronautical engineer i
probably need to do that too
i have six cars included in them are a
beautiful bright red 1969
corvette stingray and the bright red
1969 mustang grande
and they fill the garage until my new
mercedes sits out in the snow in the
rain
my uh
i have to confess that this weekend when
i went around trying to start them three
of them wouldn't start
all of which proves as you all know that
they say about
people that
if it ain't broke don't fix it well
engineers believe that if it ain't broke
it doesn't have enough features yet
my first car was a 1959
beautiful goldwing chevrolet you
remember that
and i've never forgiven life magazine
they put out an issue on the
10 ugliest cars in history and we
finished second
the fact is though that
very few people can argue that the
automobile has an enormous impact on our
lives today
certainly it's improved the lifestyles
for many many people
uh
it's just one example i happen to
notice just yesterday a copy of
of
one of these magazines that puts out a
list of the largest
in their words manufacturing companies
in the world on their list of the
largest manufacturing companies let me
read you the first dozen names as i read
about them think about what they have in
common
the order goes as follows
exxon mobil
royal dutch shell
bp general motors
daimler chrysler ford toyota general
electric got on there somehow
total chevron texaco volkswagen and
conical phillips
not hard to see the impact of the
automobile on the way we live
but as we all know there's always
another side to the
coin sadly on the order of 3 000 people
will die today in automobile accidents
around the world
in los angeles alone
some 400 000 person years will be wasted
this year
due to traffic congestion
i read a couple of years ago that today
or at that time
the average speed in traveling through
central london london on a weekday was
exactly what it was in 1850
also cars suvs and other light vehicles
produce about 16 percent of the carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases that
are produced in the united states
and as we know our appetite for oil
makes us vulnerable to actions of people
throughout some of the most contentious
areas of the world
i serve on the board of a petroleum
company and i've come up with another of
augustine's widely unremembered laws
this one says that
political instability
creates oil bearing geological
formations
that's my second newest law i'll throw
in the other one that i have a lot of
data on and that is that
tornadoes are caused by trailer parks
but it all gets much more complicated
than this and it will get more
complicated in the future
it's been estimated that there will be
70 million new cars additional cars
on u.s highways
15 years from now
and as dan roose pointed out to us this
morning so well
that if we're to solve this we have to
view it as the systems problem that it
indeed is because of the many couplings
that tied to the automobile
just yesterday i saw an example that a
friend of mine
who lives
not far from the newark airport
came down to see me in washington and it
turned out he drove his car down
and when i asked him about that he said
that his answer was he said
that the airline flight has become so
unpleasant he said i've extended my
no-fly zone from 200 to 500 miles and as
more and more people do that we're going
to see i think more and more uh
complications
uh in our traffic
patterns
well this afternoon we're going to hear
some answers about what we should do
about all this
we've got two
of the most qualified people i can
possibly imagine both
happily have been friends of mine
and
two people that i have such great
respect for their ability to think out
of the box
i you probably would know them they will
be speaking in order
uh ernie moniz
and dean kamen
just a very brief introduction so that i
don't take much of their time
ernie of course is a professor of
physics and director of energy studies
in the laboratory for energy and
environment here at mit
uh he previously served our country's
under secretary of the department of
energy
and his associate director for science
in the office of science and technology
policy
and previously he was head of the
physics department
here at mit
uh to give you an idea of the diversity
of his backgrounds
background he is a fellow of the
american association for the advancement
of science and also a member of the
council on foreign relations
i our second speaker
dean caiman uh dean is uh
probably the most innovative person i've
ever run across
uh an inventor uh extraordinaire
uh he is the inventor of the segway
vehicle that i'm sure you've seen a
great deal of on tv
in fact dean i saw one driving down the
sidewalks in washington yesterday
uh dean has we heard this morning about
how many countries are going from two
wheels to four
dean is trying to take america from four
to two
that's how far ahead he is
uh dean's uh diverse
contributions range all the way from
dialysis machines to uh
to transporters that are capable of
climbing stairs
perhaps the thing he will
be most remembered for or at least that
he should be the most remembered for in
my opinion was that he founded an
organization called first
the intention of which is to encourage
young people young boys and girls to
become interested in science technology
and to pursue careers in those fields
and hopefully he'll tell us a little bit
about that when he speaks
dean holds the national medal of
technology presented by the united
president united states
so with those introductions
let me turn to our first speaker ernie
the platform is yours
[Applause]
thank you norm uh in fact uh
having our two sessions today chaired by
uh by norman by uh by chuck vest
uh reminds me that uh certainly when i
when i was in the government
uh until roughly uh noon on january 20th
2001 uh
chuck and and norm were a fantastic
one-two punch in in washington for
promoting basic science uh promoting
university government partnerships uh
chuck kind of invented the role of the
university president speaking for this
national interest
and norm was kind of the articulate
private sector
uh industry uh spokesman uh and they
were they were very very critical voices
at that time uh for supporting basic
research so thanks again norm for that
uh that support uh back then
anyway let's turn to uh the business
and i will start with some truth in
advertising
of this
title of my talk which is really a
string of nouns oil security environment
technology
and
i will be focusing more on the fuel side
of the equation
and i must confess the truth in
advertising is that
frankly this talk or a good part of it
is really the most non-disruptive
technology uh discussion uh that you
will hear
today
it perhaps should be called the
persistence of oil
more or less the perfect transportation
fuel as john hayward alluded to this
morning
and but also discussing the forces
that may or may not ultimately curb our
increasing reliance uh on uh on oil so
let's start with kind of the praises of
oil
as a reference point uh we can go to the
kind of the folk music library uh and
recall uh john henry the steel driving
man uh who took on the steam hammer
now we're gonna do some 801
i'm sure you all remember finally your
801 uh uh arithmetic uh so let's say
that john henry lifts his 10 kilogram
sledgehammer three meters
every three seconds for ten hours that's
a pretty good day's work
three and a half megajoules
well a gallon of gasoline
for which you and i go out and pay two
dollars
deliver it to our neighborhood or
anywhere we want it
very conveniently dispense the
ambient pressure and temperature
carries about 125 megajoules
about 40 times
that day's work even with a 10 percent
efficiency say of conversion to
mechanical work
uh
pretty good deal
natural gas by the way just to give you
other uh reference points underlining
what is obviously this why we had this
transformation uh during the industrial
revolution natural gas delivered to my
house here in brookline pretty far away
from the source is about twelve dollars
a gigajoule
and coal that of course we no longer
want delivered to our neighborhoods uh
gets to the
power plant
uh somewhere
out there at about two dollars a
gigajoule
now the electricity that comes from that
plant to my house i pay about 35 dollars
per gigajoule
uh but a couple of points here one again
uh fossil fuels
are extraordinarily
good energy sources and inexpensive when
put up against any kind of rational uh
measure of what they do for us and
secondly one point that i'll come back
to in transportation noting this
electricity
delivered to your house
if translated into work
being rather more expensive
reminder or minor electricity is an
energy carrier
from the primary fuel there's a
conversion involved it's more expensive
two-thirds of the energy typically will
be lost to heat
but of course we use it because we like
its convenience
its cleanliness at the point of use
and we will and we simply can afford to
pay for it the the analog to electricity
in the transportation sector is hydrogen
an energy carrier not a primary fuel
but let me note
right now we'll come back to it later
that even liquid hydrogen
not a very convenient fuel for our cars
still has only about a quarter the
volume energy density of gasoline
and so hydrogen really is not
the best transportation fuel unless you
want to travel vertically like michael
to the space station then it's very good
that's a very good mass energy density
but
hydrogen
is unlikely
to have the impact as electricity has
due to convenience
it may have it of course due to
cleanliness and environmental concerns
and we'll come back to that uh later on
so anyway bottom line we shouldn't be
surprised fossil fuels today account for
about 85 percent of world energy use
transportation depends almost entirely
uh on on oil coal major uses in
electricity more than half of ours here
in the united states natural gas for
electricity and heating
of these the demands of mobility make
the transportation displacement of
fossil fuel probably the most difficult
to uh to contemplate so in the absence
of externalities like security of supply
and environmental stewardship
technology and performance
do not drive us to look for a changed
paradigm if you like in terms of
transportation in fact fossil fuels
uh are so valuable because they're so
cheap
and you make it up in volume base uh
basically
so i will discuss these externalities
security uh and environment to see how
they may or may not influence the
trajectory of our transportation
technologies so let's turn to security
supply
how much is there
of this stuff can i get it
and at what price
by the way the same considerations would
largely are increasingly applied to uh
natural gas first of all we are not
running out of oil
there's about a trillion barrels of
conventional reserves in the world many
decades worth
at let's say 100 million barrels per day
which we are likely to reach in say
10 or 15 years
i mean some as some like to say the
stone age did not end for lack of stones
and that's
likely
likely to be true for oil as well at
least for quite some time
now there are some problems
the distribution of this reserve
unfortunately has very poor geographical
correlation with demand
uh this is augustine's law apparently
and specifically about 57 percent of oil
reserves are in the middle east
and two-thirds are in general in opec
countries
second the cost
is likely to be increasing i say cost
and not price
as one of course is going farther along
the oil
production curve but don't forget price
is objectively speaking still
pretty low however
for alternative supply paths that we
will now come to
cost increase
can be very important in impacting the
opportunity for alternative supply to
penetrate the market now this
distribution of oil has raised major
public concerns in this country and
elsewhere since the 73 and 79 uh oil
shocks
and
and with the more recent
opec cohesion
in using market power
unfortunately starting in the 70s this
also led
to a very simple-minded definition of
our security goal
decrease imported oil
this is not a sensible statement
if you adhere
to what may be arguably the only
fragment we have of energy policy
in this country and that is a reliance
on markets
those two statements are practically
incompatible
more appropriate objectives for
advancing security
really are limiting market power by
impacting the supply-demand balance and
especially in creating more elasticity
for oil demand
so what are some sensible
technology and policy objectives to
pursue
if we want to
address
energy security in this sense and i will
offer four
pathways all of which hinge upon
technology development and the interplay
of technology and policy
well number one on the on anybody's list
really is reduce oil demand
and i want to stress not imported oil
demand oil demand
and the number one technology pathway
for addressing
the reduction in oil demand is what we
heard this morning uh particularly from
john haywood that of
higher efficiency
vehicles
and certainly and i think john would
agree since i took it from his studies
that
certainly objectives
such as 80 mile per gallon
full-size hybrid automobiles
in say a 20-25 year 20-25 year time
period with
at least arguably reasonable price
differential is not a crazy
technological dream
but one that with
wide scale deployment would have
enormous impact because remember you
don't have to displace
oil use
to address the security issue in fact
today a few million barrels a day of
elasticity or demand reduction
would have enormous impact
on any possible use of market power
by creating essentially substantially
more reserve production capacity which
currently is held almost exclusively in
saudi arabia
so oil demand efficient vehicles is
certainly
number one direction number two
diversify oil resources so i'm still not
going off of oil but diversify oil
resources
now in fact since the 70s
apparently unrecognized by policy makers
we've actually had a complete change in
how the oil market functions and part of
that is by diversifying resources
geographically across the world
but today let's focus more on technology
pathways for diversifying oil resources
because earlier that trillion barrels
that i mentioned was really essentially
so-called conventional
reserves
but there are unconventional reservoirs
by various
definitions
specifically for example canada
and venezuela
in our hemisphere of course one is an
opec member one is not
each not together but each have more
heavy oil reserves
than saudi arabia
has reserves
each with more than a quarter trillion
barrels each now there's a big
technology play here to produce that oil
economically
to
refine it it may have desulfurization
issues for example
there are production issues
fracturing uh
completion et cetera but the only only
point is to say that today in western
canada
in various places
that oil is being produced today
for fifteen dollars a barrel so this is
not some again some crazy far out um in
the future
uh
uh unattainable goal
it is it is quite real uh and and
in fact maybe your company uh norm but
certainly
major oil companies are up there in fact
rapidly increasing this now there are
the technologies that need to be refined
for this however i should say are not
only those in the production and
refining but also in things like
environmental mitigation
and this in fact may be one of the major
limitations in how rapidly those
resources can be opened up but it's a
very real pathway that we haven't paid
too much attention to uh certainly in
the policy policy community
okay that's two that's two approaches
third approach
now develop alternatives to oil
alternatives that let's say let's
restrict ourselves for this purpose to
producing
very convenient liquid fuels that you
can essentially burn in the same
combustion engines you have today
a couple of examples of these technology
pathways
converting natural gas to liquid fuel
again a very rapidly growing small on a
global scale but a rapidly growing
approach
there is a
huge amount of stranded gas in the world
stranded gas means natural gas reserves
that are because of the extra
complication and cost of transporting
gas across long distances compared to
liquids like oil
is stranded by being too far from demand
centers
once again the bad news is a very large
more than a third of the world's gas
reserves are also in the middle east but
in this case not nearly as developed as
a market because they are far from
demand centers
but many many places in the world have
huge amounts of gas
which you can get today at say 50 cents
and sometimes for free compared to say
the five dollars we're paying today in
the united states now liquefying the gas
and transporting it directly as gas
of course is growing rapidly
uh although uh certainly in this country
uh opposition to such plants is is quite
intense but also as i say this gas to
liquid
uh approach is is going well and
advances in chemistry and
and engineering
already have such
liquid fuels
produced
at let's say competitive prices
with 25
maybe 30 dollars a barrel of oil so not
out of the ballpark again of where we
are today and costs rapidly
decreasing and these fuels by the way
also often have great environmental
attractions for example diesel fuel
produced from natural gas
earns a price premium
because
uh it offers uh
lower sulfur uh and lower particulate
emissions uh in in burning another
technology pathway of the same type is
biofuels as the source now of course
uh and
ethanol is the most most prevalent uh
i want to stress that i do not mean
ethanol
derived from burning corn
as we subsidize heavily today uh burning
food is uh probably a poor way to
move your 3000 pounds of steel uh to the
to the corner store uh to get some food
but
but for example uh research on things
like enzyme development uh to break down
cellulose
uh essentially a a waste product uh are
very very promising and once again not
that far away rational predictions would
say that in 10 to 15 years we can be
talking a dollar to a dollar a quarter
unsubsidized uh cellulose-based ethanol
but technology
especially in this business with large
infrastructures
often has to be aligned with policy
one interesting suggestion made by the
energy futures coalition along this
regard if one wants to stimulate these
pathways which enhance energy security
and also have environmental benefits
for example would be
as a thought calculation
let's say take
only 10 billion dollars of our
agricultural subsidies
generally focused on
growing nothing or growing things
that third world
farmers might grow better
cheaper at least
put those into energy crops
that subsidy into energy crops
at a 50 cent per gallon subsidy
could displace 15 of our gasoline use a
huge impact now again i'm not saying
that's the policy to follow but i'm just
saying we have a lot of technologies and
policy tools that are out there right
now that we could use
uh if we had a kind of coherent energy
security
uh policy
the fourth
direction
again after
efficiency
new oil sources alternatives to oil the
fourth direction is a more profound
change
of the transportation paradigm
we'll hear some will here we'll hear
dean's version
of that for at least some particular
uses
we would have heard
dean mitchell's
[Music]
statement about city planning as a way
to alter it
but again let me let me focus on the
technology pathway certainly most
discussed in this context and that's
hydrogen and fuel cell fuel cell
vehicles
which would obviously be a major a major
shift
of those four pathways this is by far
the most problematic
and longest term
first as we already discussed
it simply is not the ideal
transportation fuel
and john hayward again referred to that
as well this morning
we know the cost problems with fuel
cells
with producing hydrogen
with storage
and with a whole new infrastructure
potentially being required
but let's just think more simply of the
scale of what it would mean to introduce
hydrogen fuel cells in cars
at a scale that really matters
because again it isn't a primary fuel
we've got to get it from some place
well this the easiest place to get it
easiest and cheapest is for natural gas
in fact there's a lot of hydrogen
produced
and some of you may not know that in
fact there are even large hydrogen
pipelines
down in the houston area for example to
serve refineries who use it to lighten
increasingly heavy or occasionally sour
crude oil
natural gas obviously mainly methane ch4
a lot of hydrogen in there so it's a
good it's a good source however
just to displace
the increment
in global oil use projected to 2025
globally just the increment
would require
75 trillion cubic feet per year of
natural gas
on an energy equivalency basis
the scale of that is that is
approximately all the natural gas
slightly less than all the natural gas
used today in the world
you can imagine a few problems
uh ramping up to that scale
of use now so maybe the answer is to go
to a
less valuable hydrogen
source
like water
electrolysis for example well standard
so-called cold electrolysis
needs about 50 kilowatt hours of
electricity to produce a kilogram of
hydrogen which in turn has the energy
equivalent of roughly a gallon of
gasoline
that translates again
once again
to displace the increment in oil use the
2025 that requires about 30 trillion
kilowatt hours of electricity per year
slightly more than twice as much as the
world uses today
now technology can help reduce these
staggering numbers
for example efficiency of end use
may get as a factor of two fuel cells
highly efficient
although one should remember that
advanced hybrids the competition is also
very efficient
or one of the competitions
and secondly uh and i in my view as
central is to find much more efficient
processes for production in fact one of
the questioners this morning alluded to
nuclear power plants as a possible
source of high temperature heat
for thermal production of hydrogen
unproved certainly today extremely
uneconomical but but there are a number
of ideas out there being pursued to
lower this cost
of of getting of getting hydrogen but
this is a long way off
and i think we cannot afford to have a
focus
on this direction
impede
are frankly more serious approaches to
addressing the transportation questions
with regard to security and environment
to which to which i will come make it
very clear this is not a statement that
we should not work on this aggressively
we should it could be a very important
approach uh in the long term
and the fact that it costs a lot man
deter us again remember the story with
electricity we're very happy to pay
three times more
per unit of energy for electricity in
our houses
because we don't want to burn
you know coleman lamps uh for light for
uh for example but we should understand
what we're getting into with the energy
carrier of paying a premium for
convenience
and especially in this case with
hydrogen for clean
end use
so the punch line really here is that
a coherent energy security policy
built around especially the first three
objectives in the next say a couple of
decades
really could do much to resolve security
supply
together with easily imaginable
technology development we aren't asking
for a miracle
and evolutionary
energy infrastructure
uh development more efficiency new
reserves
and alternatives to oil and this does
not require
behavioral change of any
major
consequence
now
clearly these pathways also
uh lead to environmental benefits
for example efficiency uh in the use of
let's say gasoline and an advanced
hybrid
cuts down emissions dramatically and the
fuels that go into those vehicles
themselves
have to be much cleaner much lower
sulfur levels
etc
in fact
if you think back to what we often
confuse as energy policy
the externalities of security
environment
in many ways
led to the policies that have had the
most profound effect on on the evolution
of transportation as opposed to any any
specific energy policy in particular i
refer to the cafe standards we heard
about this morning which were a result
of security concerns following the 73
oil embargo and secondly the clean air
act
and its amendments in 1990 have had
profound impacts on fuels and the design
of of engines
so
the good news is those security
directions
also give you
environmental benefits particularly for
the local
and regional levels smog etc
however let me finish up by a short
focus on climate change
and let me
first give you my framework
and some of you may argue with these
later on
first
we are clearly
and undeniably in my view
re-engineering the atmosphere
one-third increase in co2 concentrations
for example
since pre-industrial
uh on a scale
that poses risk
in a 50-100 year time scale and
emphasize the word risk
the time scale for turning over the
energy infrastructure is multi-decadal
somewhat shorter for transportation but
unfortunately longer for
power plants and certainly for buildings
three
the scale of the challenge
in addressing greenhouse gas emissions
which is basically contemplating
perhaps a factor of two to two and a
half times increased energy use globally
by mid-century
while holding carbon emissions at or
below today's level
is an immense
challenge
fourth
prudence
demands that we start now
especially with the very many
no regrets technology deployments that
we could put forward some of which we
just discussed in terms of alternative
fuels for example
and fifth
it doesn't matter
where the carbon i'll say carbon carbon
dioxide
comes from doesn't matter where it comes
from geographically doesn't matter
whether it comes from a mobile or a
fixed source
because there are very very long
hundreds of years residence times in the
atmosphere and essentially global global
mixing so wherever the source comes from
has the same
same impact and this in my view suggests
that market forces should and will be
the principal approach to meeting
emissions reduction requirements
no matter what those requirements turn
out to be
that is market in the sense of finding
the lowest cost way
of reducing carbon with trading etc
this has a very important implication
for transportation
it is simply easier to mitigate
emissions
both technically and politically
for stationary
sources politically
i assume we could take a poll here but
let me let me make a guess
most of you have one vote
in
upcoming elections
some may have more but
from chicago i know from from chicago uh
you have approximately one car
maybe more norm has five but they aren't
all being driven so it doesn't count
and you probably don't have a coal plant
you are a constituency that will favor
controlling carbon at stationary sources
rather than
mobile sources
now
hydrogen derived
from renewable sources or nuclear power
or renewable biofuels specifically
directly going into let's say a
combustion engine
would of course avoid carbon from
transportation
we use a lot of oil however
as we already alluded to
in fact we use oil globally at the rate
the average rate of more than 5
trillion
watts
if we used half of the cultivatable land
in the world
to produce biofuels
we might be able to get using that same
metric
a couple trillion watts maybe
so biofuels could be very important but
they're not quotes the answer to the
problem certainly in and of themselves
and
hydrogen we've seen all the problems
that it has in terms of the costs etc
and again
remember it's a carrier and therefore if
we get the hydrogen from natural gas we
still have the carbon problem
in fact john haywood has shown that
a hybrid would perform as well life
cycle as a hydrogen vehicle in terms of
carbon emissions
if you don't capture the carbon and put
it away
so
what's the what's an alternative
i'm not suggesting this is the way it
will go but i just want to emphasize the
interplay between technology
markets and policy
your gallon of gasoline the one that you
and i buy for two dollars
it's got about two and a half kilograms
of carbon in it
virtually all of it
essentially released as co2 after
combustion
if
serious carbon constraints are imposed
there's an expectation that one way or
another
a price
will be assigned to emitting carbon
through a market mechanism
at somewhere between 50 and 100
per ton of carbon
today we cannot capture carbon
following combustion at that at that
price with today's technology it's more
like 200 but it's got to come down for
this
for this to work well that
even a hundred dollars a ton of carbon
is therefore
25 cents
per gallon of gasoline
that may be higher than john's five cent
tax
but 25 cents
is not enormous and that brings us back
therefore to another policy technology
pathway
if it is simpler
to
um
avoid the carbon
in other sources especially stationary
sources
that may be part of the trading market
where in effect
the mobile source pays
25 cents a gallon for the gasoline
and it goes to support a renewable or
some other kind of project uh that is
avoiding carbon emissions again i don't
know which pathway will be followed but
i just want to emphasize this again a
strong interplay of technology markets
and
uh and policy
so in summing up
in my axioms with regard to climate
change
i noted the time scale
we need to get going
because we have a 50 to 100 year horizon
for possibly dramatic action
in the energy sector
and it takes that long to turn over many
parts of the energy infrastructure
there's a story
told of a
french
general leote
who upon returning this was some over
100 years ago upon returning to france
after a long campaign
asked his gardener to plant a particular
type of tree at his chateau
the gardener protested
that such a tree
takes a hundred years to mature
allegedly at least leota's response was
then he better plant it that afternoon
because there was no there was no time
to waste
and i think that's very much the spirit
with which we have to address
this climate change problem
so with that i have the pleasure i think
of turning over the podium to dean kamen
norm said a few things about dean
i'll just add
a couple more
dean is a character as many of you know
and
with his wonderful us first uh
enterprise with these kids a little
little anecdote was uh
dean brought the two finalist teams uh i
don't forget when 96 maybe uh 95 96
to the white house
for
al gore to play with
and
al showed a little bit too much skill
at manipulating these things for someone
who
certainly was focused on broad issues of
national policy but gore did manage
at the instigation of various people and
i think dean was one of them to finally
manage to manipulate to drop one of the
big beach balls on my head as a
demonstration
of how these how these wonderful tools
the kids made worked
dean also can tell you great stories
about his windmills he's
very environmentally committed quite
clearly
but let me not say any more and just
have dean come up and talk about a
different way of changing the paradigm
[Applause]
all i learned today so far is the best
fuel
is the fuel you don't need
i heard at lunch
from chuck fest how seriously you all
consider your ranking in the world
compared to other
academic institutions so i thought at
least i'll get some favor here by giving
you some good news and some great news
the good news is i'm not alumni
and the great news is i didn't graduate
from harvard princeton or yale either
i um
i was anticipating it would be a
panel format so you're particularly
lucky i don't have a lot of slides or a
presentation
but i did after listening
to this morning
by some luck have a
500 meg little
device in my pocket which had some
fun pictures on it that i thought i'd
start with and then maybe try to tell
you a little bit about this
are we going to be able to do that boss
in a moment
i would have to start out by telling you
that
everything i listened to today made me
realize that half of the great data i
quote comes from people like joe
coughlin and
professor hayward
so
i can't possibly with any credibility
talk in detail about
the various aspects either of the
technology of
the infrastructure of
of
transportation so i'll just give you a
very
contracted history
with respect to how i think this thing
might
let's say fit into what might be the
future
now that he's got this
this picture up
again i'll start
you probably think i'd show this picture
it says stop here i'm in trouble
because
we're in the oval office with the
president
that's not why
um
really here for a couple of reasons one
everywhere i go
i have to tell people about first and
get more support for it
and so yes we were getting the national
medal of technology and yes it's the
oval office and yes being in an ibot i
was nearly eye level with this guy
but we're discussing first and he's
making his commitment to bring the
winners of our competition to be
recognized in the white house which he
in fact did do
hello
very quickly
this picture is here
i guess in part because we were proud
that our technology and ibot helped the
disabled get around
was recognized and we won the national
medal of technology with it
but my
point in showing this picture really is
much more important than that
it's not the ibot in the oval office
it's the fact that the president and i
are
discussing and he is committing to bring
the winners of our first competition our
annual event that's what this is all
about
uh to be recognized in the white house
which he in fact did do
so that made it a successful trip the
other reason i like to show this picture
is because i'm trying to debunk the
common
myth that when the occasion demands it
i can in fact be a snappy dresser
and so
here i am
the other reason i wanted to show this
slide is because we're here to talk
about
issues of technology and
transportation in particular but i just
think it's in general new technologies
typically these days more than ever
technology is moving much faster than
the ability of people and cultures to
absorb it
and
as a proof of that i figured i'd first
show the expected and intended
consequence of our
ability to understand human balance and
bring this now after a couple of decades
of effort
this medically approved class 3 device
to people that can't walk
and
then to point out that sometimes and i
think inevitably technology
brings you unexpected results
so here's the expected and intended
consequence
a president of the united states
recognizing the importance of balancing
technology by the way there is clearly
balance in the oval office
and
here's the unintended but inevitable
consequence of balancing or almost
balancing technology
this is the current president of the
united states this is a segway
they work a lot better when you turn
them on
[Applause]
you've got to plan and you've got to
know what you're getting into in this
world
anyway
louder
sorry
the next one is to show that i also can
appreciate the broad range of technology
you need for transportation and if you
happen to get your 10 000 pound humvee
stuck in the snow and you happen to have
an ibot
i was a little concerned here because i
checked and this cable's only good to 30
000 pounds a pull
but
that was a happy experiment
this
is a slide that was done by leon creer
most of you may know he's a pretty
renowned architect
and without any prompting by us or
anybody at segway i was asked to go down
to washington where thousands of
architects city
urban planning types were getting
together and he put this slide giving us
great
recognition for it but he put this slide
up this is a satellite view of
washington dc
this was the amount of washington you
could cover in a five-minute walk
and this is the amount ten times by area
the amount you could cover
on a five minute segway trip
and he went on to talk about the 21st
century needs to rethink
how we architect cities
given the right tools
so it's in the spirit of that that i'd
like to make a couple of quick
observations
as somebody who's always trying to
convince the world that maybe we should
re-look at the fundamental issues
i should use one of norm augustine's
laws in which i think he said
the early bird catches the worm
the early worm gets
eaten i've spent most of my life as the
worm
uh
but it's okay
so in in a very contracted
uh piece of history i'll let me tell you
the history of the world of
transportation as i see it as a person
who spent 30 years building medical
equipment and only as a result of that
ibot sort of segwayed into this
so
it got really cold the dinosaurs died
and then people came and people stand up
and walk on two feet
that takes care of about the first 100
million years or so then
then we invented the most important
technology of all time for humanity the
plow and we went from hunter-gatherers
to organized societies and even in the
very first organized societies you'd be
happy to know
there was congestion
in ancient greece
when the known population was 1.5
million people
the law in ancient greece said you could
not bring your horse your ox and cart
inside the city walls from one hour
before sunrise until one hour after
sunset they were already worried about
congestion where people want to live in
city environments and already had
figured out it's not a place for big
equipment to be
miscellaneously mingling with a
pedestrian environment
that was an interesting lesson
a few thousand years went by and every
few hundred years some major piece of
transportation technology changed the
world
figured out how to build boats found the
compass that's why we're all in north
america that changed the world
we built locomotives interesting we're
talking about energy and when we built
the first engines to move things
everybody thinks we start small and get
big that's not true we built locomotives
to run
trains
and at least 50 years before we were
moving cars around we had these
multi-hundred ton machines they turned
the continent into a country because we
could move things around very
efficiently
and that changed the way we perceive
life
all the while for a few thousand years
cities were growing up
now we get to the year 1903
henry ford decides wouldn't it be great
if we had the next big change
in transportation and he was right
but he was dealing with the situation
that you could move great big heavy
stuff easily
in trains you could get stuff across an
ocean in boats
individuals were very happy believe it
or not walking around cities
the problem was that
that intermediate space the small towns
to the small towns the small towns to
the railroad stations with their crops
or with their manufactured goods or
getting around farms
they wanted to change the horse and
buggy
to the horseless buggy the horse and
carriage was too slow
didn't carry enough and it was twice as
long as just the carriage alone
so if you could take a technology to
make the thing half as big and twice as
fast you win
a snapshot in time of the year 1903.
about 154 million people on the planet
lived in cities it was 9 of the human
population 91 of the world lived in a
rural agrarian environment the 9 that
lived in all the cities were happy
walking around they didn't have a
problem
the car was intended for that other 91
percent to solve a big problem and
improve the way we all live and work and
it worked
it worked so well that by the 1950s
we're building the highway systems
across this country and across the world
and it's it's the eighth wonder of the
world they're the largest public works
projects ever done
and we can take them for granted if you
want but they're extraordinary
and you've heard all sorts of
prognostications on the future of the
car and you could be disappointed that
we're only getting them better at one
percent per year but that's not because
they're bad that's because they're so
damn good
it's about the cheapest piece of
technology you buy pound for pound and
you put it out on the highway and it's
65 miles an hour you can go in almost
complete safety
between cities
take your whole family with you stay
warm all winter stay cool all summer
everybody loves them it's not surprising
it's the largest industry on the planet
you just heard the list of all the
companies that support it
it's a problem that in fact
existed and was solved and for a hundred
years it was great
now some new data
a hundred years goes by
and for the first time in human history
including the greeks 50
of the human population for the first
time in history this decade more people
live in cities or mega cities
than any other environment 3.2 billion
people and it's the only part of the
global human population that's
increasing his cities and mega cities
in asia alone
if there were no further births the
expectation is in the next 20 years 800
million people will move into cities or
mega cities
800 million 20 years just asia
you can divide that out
if the average city had 10 million
people
manhattan 10 million people to get 800
million need 80 cities
80 cities in 20 years that's one every
six weeks
so let's build a city of the size and
density of manhattan every six weeks for
the next 20 years that will only deal
with the population migration of just
the people already alive just in asia
then you heard that everybody wants to
use cars you heard all sorts of data
and i can't help it but
getting one percent more fuel economy
each year as tough as that would be and
as remarkable as it will be to get to
80 gallons 80 miles per gallon it still
seems to me when you're talking about
population swings and 10 billion people
on the planet in 30 years
and all of them expecting to join the
quote middle class all of them trying to
get at least out of abject poverty the
idea that we're going to do with these
one percent improvements year by year is
like swatting at the flies while we're
getting trampled by the
elephants so
what's the good news
the good news to me
was after we spent a couple of decades
trying to figure out how to understand
human balance for the sole purpose i
wish i could say that this was some
great vision for the sole purpose of
helping the disabled community who
couldn't walk at all
we made an ibot
we made that thing that helps people get
up and be at eye level and walk up and
down stairs and have dignity
but the
technical challenge of understanding
human balance understanding that when
you kind of want to walk forward you
just think about taking a step and you
go
or you want to back up you kind of think
about backing up understanding human
balance and
implementing it in a simple device
as difficult as it might seem maybe i'm
just naive
but i just had enormous
confidence that i have the kind of
people that can do it by the way many of
them are your alums a few of them are
here now
john marley's here
john kerwin is here derek kane is here i
just have infinite confidence that i'd
like it to be weeks they tell me it'll
be months it takes years but we'll do it
we'll solve it we'll make the technology
work and i've never doubted that we made
the ibot and immediately my concern was
would we ever get this thing through the
food and drug administration and allow
people that need it to use it will we
ever get rational people to accept that
this technology poses quote reasonable
risk
for grandma on a staircase and the
answer was yes
took 100 million dollars it took a lot
of years but we got it through the fda
instantly we had this thing
and i said you know
every project we've ever done we license
off to some big company who can
efficiently bring it to the world we
went to johnson and johnson the world's
largest medical products company with
the ibot
who could i take this to
instantly in looking at it i said well
there's a lot of companies that might
think
it's the equivalent of the urban
version
of a snowmobile or a jet ski or an atv
or some other recreational toy it is fun
it can zip around
but i couldn't do it because i just had
been thinking about some of the things i
just told you
and said
technology's been brought to bear in
every form of human transportation even
in my own lifetime i've watched us go
from earthbound to i watched when i was
in high school
a human being stepped on the moon
and all i could think of was if half the
human population is now living in cities
i mean a city needs a car
like a fish needs a bicycle
and and all i can think of is we've got
to give people a new alternative because
left to their own devices
if they don't have one we'll keep doing
what we've been doing and all the forces
market forces that you've seen will keep
making it seem reasonable to people that
cars belong in the middle of cities
so here's some more data
you talk about one percent more
efficiency
of the gasoline used for transportation
in the united states last year was used
in cars sitting in traffic
or going less than eight miles an hour
well you can play on the edges of all
these problems but recognize cars are
great when used the way they're supposed
to be used
and i mean i have an airplane and i
don't feel guilty about it i get into
that thing i climb to 41 000 feet i
scream along at mach 0.8 i'm a happy
camper and i can cross this continent in
a few hours
and boeing can put everybody in this
room in a machine like that cross the
continent in a few hours that's a
remarkable achievement and we shouldn't
feel badly about it
but when we land we were smart enough to
build an infrastructure that said we
leave our airplanes at the airport
nobody i know would complain to lockheed
or to boeing it's a really nice machine
but that last few miles getting it home
it's clipping down the you know the
trees on my neighbor's lawn
its mileage on the taxiway is awful
well we all laugh at that but the fact
is you want to go 600 miles i'd suggest
you get in an airplane it goes 600 miles
an hour an hour later you can be just
about anywhere on the continent then you
get into a car it goes 60 miles an hour
you spend a half an hour in it going
anywhere you want to go from any airport
and then you get to that last couple of
miles
where half the human population lives
and that's where all the problem is
well you're not going to fix it in the
way you designed the airplane or in the
way you designed the car you're going to
leave your airplane at the airport
you're going to take your car
for what it was ideally designed to do
relatively high speed ground
transportation
convenient efficient relatively
efficient safe
and then when you get to where people
live in high dense environments give
them another alternative
now you could say well it won't work so
my last
set of data and again i i've heard
different people quoting different
pieces of it
but there's been multiple studies on
this because efficiency and cost and
time is the most important thing humans
have
and there have been loads of studies
done in the last 10 years that'll tell
you 500 years ago it took six years to
cross the ocean a hundred years ago it
took six months fifty years ago it took
six weeks
five years ago started taking six hours
no matter what the advancements in tech
in technology and transportation have
been phenomenal except the greeks walked
from the theater of dionysus to the
parthenon
by slapping on their sandals and
cruising along at two miles an hour
you want to go from the center of the
known universe the carnegie deli on 57th
street down to the empire state building
you slap on your sneakers and your
cruise at two miles an hour
there's been not only no change
but cities have gotten bigger because
the population is now six billion people
even the cities are just huge they're
mega cities
secondly
because cars have invaded them and
spread them out
the actual density that you need to make
a city survive is has been jeopardized
except for the really large cities most
cities haven't survived the car
if you need to get into a car to go to
some place in a city
you're going to get on the highway and
go out to the suburb
that's why most mid-size and small
cities have disappeared or they're
downtowns or thrift shops and junk that
can't compare and compete
with the mall or the sprawl or the
walmart and then so when things like the
education
you know the rest of the story
you might ask yourself the real question
then why does everybody spend all
morning driving into the city sitting in
traffic for two hours and driving out
because cities are the most
anthropogenic invention of humanity we
want to live and work together we want
to be clustered and almost everybody in
the 20th century including
what were the great visionaries like
robert moses that invented this concept
of let's spend all of our day and all of
our energy sloshing in it going in
opposite directions
did it
because i think they really forgot that
fact
but
a city
to us that aren't
urban designers anthropologists and
sociologists is a place
where you can get up and where you can
work and eat and play and see the arts
without having to
do other things that's why people built
cities including the greeks
but the last piece of data which is over
the last 10 years been proven out in the
richest cities in the world
and the poorest cities whether you go to
bangkok mexico city paris london the
average speed in the average city in the
world
is eight miles an hour from a point of
departure to a point of destination
eight miles an hour
everybody sits here and says it's
outrageous
everybody sits in the back of that cab
and says it's outrageous and they watch
the meter go to 20 bucks but they don't
get out
everybody sits in their car and says
it's outrageous
but they don't get out why
because as bad as eight miles an hour is
it's only relative to the 60 miles an
hour that you knew that car was designed
to go and it was going until you got to
the edge of the city
the other reason you don't get out is
you know damn well you walk at two miles
an hour
so 40 minutes
in that car
or sorry
10 minutes in that cab at eight miles an
hour
is 40 minutes of walking nobody's going
to give up that half hour at each end of
the trip nobody
no matter what it costs no matter how
inconvenient it is eight miles an hour
is still the best option you have
you go to any big city that happens to
have buses and it happens to have
subways and happens to have cabs
the cool arbiter of competition is said
no matter which one you choose it ends
up about eight miles an hour because if
one was substantially better you'd use
it and that's the good news if one was
substantially better you'd use it
well what if you could be in that city
at 59th street and you want to get down
to 34th street and you could do it at
8 miles an hour
i am now going 8 miles an hour
i'm not getting tired i take up as much
room as any other pedestrian
i can bump into people and i'm
compliant like other people if i ran
into somebody here i'd probably hit my
nose against you not the fork of a
bicycle which actually takes as much
room to turn around as a car
i can stop and i can back up i can stand
in crowds i'm just a hyper pedestrian
what if you could take 3.2 billion
people and say you know technology has
given us everything from the first
sailing ships
to little machines that just landed on
mars a few months ago
but technology's never helped the
pedestrian
and it really didn't matter because even
by 1903 there was only 9 of the world
and they were happy their cities were
small and compressed
what if you could go and give to a
pedestrian environment an alternative
that would eliminate
the need for cars in these places and
even if you made your car very clean and
very efficient
you still don't need a 3000 pound pile
of steel to move your 150 pound butt
around town and it's still not going to
solve the problems of congestion and
parking and everything else
but if you could give people that live
in these environments an alternative
that's
non-polluting that's fun to use that
fits in a pedestrian environment that
doesn't even need any change in
infrastructure
it needs a change that's way tougher to
do a change in thinking
but uh
supposing people
could accept the idea that pedestrians
ought to have a choice
everybody that wants to go less than a
block or so uses their sneakers
everybody that's going more than a few
miles is going to use public transit or
a car
but something like 65 percent of all
trips in automobiles and cities are less
than two miles
if you wiped all of those out maybe
downtowns would become fun
exciting efficient clean urban
environments again
so we thought this would be fun
as i said i'm clearly
unfortunately mr augustine you're always
right i am clearly finding that where
the worm
i think it is highly likely that
like jet skis and snowmobiles and dirt
bikes of which there are millions sold
per year
these will be attractive to people
the question is
how long will it take before people can
accept that cities ought to open their
minds and deal with their real problems
i was told
the day we
started putting these things together
there was no chance we would be able to
go into a major city or state in this
country and get them to change the law
that's something that has motors and
wheels i.e a motor vehicle would be
allowed on the sidewalk
i pointed out it would be nuts
to assume this thing belongs in the
street in front of a bus
again i'm not a sophisticated urban
planner or anything like that but it
just seemed to me i wouldn't want my
mother on this thing in front of
a 40-ton bus
i went to washington
and went to visit the appropriate
agencies and there are plenty of them
including the united states department
of transportation
and in one meeting in one hour talking
to very senior people there they all
agreed
this thing doesn't belong on our roads
you sort of look like an act like and
move like any other pedestrian i was in
his office moving around shaking hands
he said okay as far as we're concerned
you're not a vehicle
i was enthusiastic
i came home only to have the great
experts and lobbyists say dean
you just entered hyperspace
you're now not a legal vehicle that
doesn't mean you are a set of hyper
sneakers you just don't have any plays
you can't be on the sidewalk because
you're not a pedestrian and now you've
been told you're not a vehicle
okay
we went state by state we were then told
by the way the feds don't have the
authority to say we're on
sidewalks
i went first to the state i live in
to see the governor and i said we're a
rare unique little state that doesn't
really have congestion and pollution
problems but we do have a neat idea
and the world's
problem today
in terms of transportation is in the
cities and we're sort of where henry
ford was in
we're solving a different problem for a
different group of people that's 20
times larger by population
maybe you could help and they passed a
law that said if it does what this does
it has the footprint of two points like
a person if it can stop and back up and
maneuver like a pedestrian it's a
pedestrian
that's big thinking you got to
understand
stay with me here
over the next six or seven months i and
a couple of people from our little
company of zealots went and visited
personally visited just about every
state in the country governors
departments of transportation
legislatures
and
i think within six months it was like 38
it's now 45 states have passed
legislation that at least gives this
thing the option to exist to determine
whether it can be compatible with
pedestrians
i thought that was quite an achievement
for a tiny little startup
that wasn't good enough either
because
and probably our most famous uh
pr
isn't the president
falling off one of these
it's the city of san francisco
which banned them before even seeing one
i went out there
to go talk to them
i was literally spit on by a group of
protesters that were stamping with
with
banners
that read
stop the segway slaughter
i tried to have a conversation with
these people
i asked them if they knew that last year
in this country 44
000 people were killed in cars one and a
half million people were hospitalized by
cars nobody knows how many people
have other illnesses as a result of the
issues
of the high density of pollution made in
cities and that's just in the u.s
they didn't want to hear about that
then one of them said to me people are
going to get really fat
because of this
the woman that said that
political correctness i will tell you
was not petite
and i said that would be a fair
criticism if i was explaining to you
that i'm selling exercise equipment
i'm selling transportation that's clean
and neat and easy and every piece of
technology that's ever been marketed
has a single goal to reduce human effort
to do something a calculator is mental
effort but cars and buses and trains are
all
i asked her if she beat her clothes
against a rock in the morning or did she
use a washing machine because her arms
look a little flat
but
i got inside and i was told by a
credible
or at least an elected official that we
would be permanently banned before we
were ever allowed on the sidewalk
because their city had no problem
they don't have a problem so i don't
know what you're all here about because
there is no problem
he then said
could i prove it was quote perfectly
safe
perfectly safe
i said well i can't prove it's perfectly
safe because if i was just standing on
it on the corner of one of your
sidewalks minding my own business i
could get run over by an suv which
weighs 5 000 pounds it could kill me
i don't know how to answer most of the
questions we've had to deal with
but we have now spent
more time
and more money
trying to just give this thing the
opportunity to exist in an environment
we've now got a few hundred thousand
hours of use
and i think our safety record is pretty
astounding
most of the other metrics that would be
used comparing it to other forms of
transportation including walking
give us a pretty favorable outcome
i don't know
what if anything
any of you
can
or should do about what the next
generation of
transportation is going to look like but
if we remember that the world
now has most of its people living in
cities and in the next 20 years
essentially all of its people to get out
of poverty to get educated
to enjoy some standard living we'll be
essentially living in cities
it'll be the model like the us two
percent of the people farm
we have to come up with a better way to
make cities viable
and just dealing with efficiency numbers
on internal combustion engines hybrid
machines or electric cars isn't going to
deal with the biggest piece of the
biggest problem i don't know that this
is the solution but at least
we tried
it's
amazing to me that as i said before
technology seems to be making more and
more possible
but people are not only not
opening their minds to faster and faster
change people are growing inward
i think technology i've come to learn is
ought to be defined as anything
that you weren't familiar with as a kid
and
i mean you know
to my grandparents
airplanes with technology and telephones
of technology to my parents televisions
kids today do not think computers or the
internet are technology
they're a commodity they're part of the
infrastructure
but
the thing that has to change to solve
the problems there's enough technology
sitting on the shelf to do it
the goal i think is to get enough smart
technical people
to start being in positions that really
help decisions get made in a rational
way
this world is addicted to oil
i mean if they were growing brussels
sprouts
in iran i'm not sure we'd be in exactly
the position we're in right now
but i
and i'm not saying that's good or bad
technology is out there technology
people generally aren't exercising an
appropriate
percentage of the decision-making
in a very complicated world and i think
the world is right now just look at it
read the news
the world's sort of in a race between
technology and catastrophe
and unless technology savvy people start
making the decision catastrophe is going
to win
and
we ought to be a little more responsible
i have along those lines one last segue
it's only a three minute long piece
along the lines of getting more people
to understand and appreciate technology
particularly women and minorities which
are virtually left out of that whole
game in the united states
and because
for a whole lot of reasons which they'll
never give me enough time to talk about
we started an organization with one of
your i think
a man that you should be very proud of
professor woody flowers
he's a fantastic guy
and and being the equal opportunity
offender that i am i went to see him
probably 10 or 12 years ago and said i
know 270 is a great course and i know
you're very proud that we fill a place
up every year to go watch this thing but
convincing students at mit that science
and technology is really fun exciting
and important to me is a pretty low
threshold
let's
let's convince
the other 99.9 percent of the country in
the world of that same statement but
let's use the tools
of your competitions
and let's make sure we get a lot of
women and minorities turned on
now that was long before the current
popular political issues about
outsourcing and jobs
but if you need
again to have your own enlightened
self-interest as to why you should be
involved with first
last year in the united states we
graduated 62 000 engineers
i won't tell you how many people
graduated with degrees in sports
literally they have to get degrees in
that now sports
or how many lawyers we graduated but we
graduated 62 000 engineers
india and china last year graduated 3.4
million people with technical degrees
now we're good and i think competition
is great and frankly i think it's great
that they're doing that if the whole
world can become net
problem solvers and producers that's
better than having
a few halves and a lot of have nots i'd
rather have all these people curing the
diseases i'm going to end up with
but americans also like to have a high
standard of living
we also like being number one well that
was easy when besides having all our
other advantages
and a culture that
that loved
innovators and entrepreneurs and risk
takers and inventors
it was also easy when we were producing
most of the scientists and engineers and
the ones from foreign countries that
came and got those degrees stayed here
62 000 3.4 million
62 000 this is not a good time to think
that women and minorities shouldn't even
be part of our pool they shouldn't even
be on the bench ready to be part of our
competitive team and think that somehow
as a birthright america is going to stay
on top
so 10 years ago we started an
organization to convince kids
that science and engineering is for
anybody willing to work at it
and all the stereotypes about
engineering and science need to be
broken down and discarded
and i went around to a bunch of inner
city schools and said to a whole bunch
of kids that first year there were 23
teams that participated you should get
on a first team it's every bit as much
fun as basketball or football and oh by
the way i know you all work out four
hours a day
you're all
going to be the next michael jordan
all you do is give them data even 14
year olds get the data the probability
that anybody in this school will ever
make a nickel playing professional
sports is way way less than the
probability that you'll win a state
lottery
there's five professional guys on each
team on that basketball court
they give out thousands of lotteries and
by the way there's a few million
exciting technical careers out there
waiting for people that know how to
think
23 major companies including lockheed
agreed to adopt a local school
we played a six-week program just like
every other high school season it was
intense it was short they played with
the real mentors michael jordan of
lockheed
showed up at these schools
these kids develop relationships with
adults
and it worked
it changed their perspectives it changed
the outcomes we now have an 11 year very
well documented history of what happens
to dropout rates graduation rates career
choices
particularly among women and minorities
we grew from 23 schools doing it once
at the end of six weeks in a high school
gym in manchester
the next year we were about 50 then
about 100. by the fifth year we were so
big we couldn't do our event in new
hampshire we did it on stage at disney
for the next five years we started doing
regional events in cities around the
country first in two cities in the sixth
year then four then eight
last year we were so big we couldn't do
our final event at disney
we
did it in the astrodome in houston
and we had 23 cities holding regionals
little cities new york detroit chicago
los angeles san jose cleveland seattle
houston orlando
and this year we didn't have 23 cities
you know the economy's down travel is
tough
and we didn't have 800 teams
we had 26 cities we've never lost a
regional
and we had nearly a thousand corporate
sponsors that adopted a thousand high
schools we gave out five million dollars
in scholarships at the nationals which
were held this year at the home of the
1996 olympics the georgia dome
and oh by the way
just as you would expect the trappings
of a culture of sports in this country
we get what we celebrate and until we
start celebrating the right things
we're in trouble
but after 10 years of work by the
seventh year of running this even in
these inner city schools the demand was
so high among the younger brothers and
sisters of these kids that we had to
start a little league version of the
sport using lego and even though we've
only been running that for four years
this year besides having a thousand high
schools there are feeder schools around
the country we had
415 middle schools with teams
i am sad to tell you that in this
intellectual capital of the country at
least we think we are
boston is conspicuously absent in two
things
there's no regional event in boston
for a technology-based program that's
essentially
woody flowers program on steroids
and
technically segways are not legal in
this city because obviously this city
has no parking or traffic problems but i
would just think that
anyway
there was a two minute and 38 second
video
it's now three or four years old i use
this not because it's the only one
because it's so short and it's an abc
world news tonight piece which i really
like for two reasons it sort of gets it
but it's just so funny how it ends
every year i invite all the media i can
to come to these things because we want
to get the word out
jack smith goes down because charlie
gibson from abc sends him down and says
he shows up at epcot this is three years
ago
and he says
he sees us it's like olympic village we
probably had four or five hundred teams
at that point and this guy says to me
why didn't you tell us it was like this
i've been telling you that year after
year but
you guys
people change slowly
trust me i know
he goes out he comes back a few minutes
later and you'll see there's two people
he interviewed that he gets on this
little news piece
one of them is a hispanic kid
from san jose
and he said dean i just met this
unbelievable kid
he was in a street gang last year he's
on parole
and now he's working with nasa on and
he's down in the pits it's unbelievable
i said jack what's what's so
unbelievable he was a leader of our
street gang now he's leadership is
leadership he just changed gangs
so he disappears he goes away and he
comes back a little while later and he
tells me tina i just met this this young
african-american woman
never met her father her mother is
living is homeless her two older
siblings have dropped out of school
nobody in her family has ever gone to
college she's on a team
down in los angeles with jpl
jack now i know why they give you guys
the big bucks you guys in the media are
amazing you were able to come here to
florida and pick out the two kids
that are exactly like the other thirty
thousand it's amazing
it's amazing how he could do that
anyway he does this show
and
it turned out pretty good so i asked
them to send me a copy
and i figured i'd use it to hook people
on that i'm not kidding it's an exciting
program
they sent it to me and when it ends with
the typical and that's our news tonight
they didn't cut it right off they let it
dribble two seconds or three seconds
into the next story
the first time i showed it people
started laughing when it was over
and then i listened to what he's saying
so if if you if you and i i just want to
assure you that i did not dub two
disparate news stories together
reality is way more ridiculous than my
imagination could ever
do and if you don't believe that our
culture is just it's not what we don't
have enough of in this country great
universities great it's what we have too
much of
nonsense
and noise that's preventing kids from
figuring out what's important in life
we ran in 26 cities we ran a few
thousand rounds of unbelievably gracious
competitions we had not a single
wardrobe malfunction the entire year
but
but look at this video then i'll tell
you where these two kids are because
it's old now
and look at the next piece that that
charlie gibson goes into and i swear to
you i did not dub them together this is
the reality of the american culture can
we see this thing
finally tonight not your ordinary
science fair
each year the u.s is short a million
scientists and engineers and so there's
every attempt to make this work enticing
an example what happened this weekend in
orlando 15 000 teenagers from 270 high
schools all across the country vying to
prove that they can build a better robot
here's abc's jack smith
it looks like a rock concert
or maybe a sports championship but this
is actually a high school science
competition
this is how you get dates yes
[Music]
the object is for competing robots to
place as many balls as possible in a
raised trough
then force their way onto a central ramp
and if possible hook the bar and hang
from it there's probably more
cheerleaders here in pep squads and
than at the ncaa finals we're trying to
get to the kids that never really
thought about science and engineering as
possible for them particularly women and
minorities and more than a third of the
students here are women and minorities a
lot of girls on our team really weren't
really looking into engineering or any
mathematical fields now over half the
team wants to go into some career in
science students have to raise their own
money robots cost around five thousand
dollars and they have just six weeks to
build them they get to work with real
engineers as opposed to the theory of it
they get to meet mentors they get shown
things they get a whole learning
experience that's in a fun environment
this is what most american children need
adult presence
you know and they don't get it so here
they're getting it definitely attention
from adults at the finals one of the
teams is captained by a senior from
california kenny vargas that's him on
the right
and his team wins
it's a special moment because kenny
who's headed for college just last year
was in a street game you know i never
accomplished anything in my life nobody
ever told me you know i was uh good at
anything and then you know i saw that i
i saw that i was good at something and i
said you know i could be good in other
areas if i just put all my effort
towards it lessons not only about
technology but also about life at this
most unusual of high school competitions
jack smith abc news orlando florida
and that is our report on world news
tonight later on nightline can a woman
teach rich young athletes how to live
better i'm charles gibson we hope you
have a good evening
i'm not making this up
[Music]
i'm not making it up really
our friend kenny vargas graduated that
year and with a little help from his
friends from nasa the team that he was
on out there in
san jose they helped get him into a
local trade school on the west coast
where he was graduating this year from
berkeley
with a degree in
mechanical engineering
lauren lyons stayed in school another
two years she's now only going to be
coming a junior but
two years ago
with a little help from the people from
jpl and los angeles the team she stayed
on for three years they got her into a
little local trade school on the east
coast called princeton university
at the end of her first year there she
found
that much to her dismay
princeton hadn't adopted a school among
the thousand teams we have about
companies that adopt a school and about
a hundred are universities that adopt a
school
and she lauren decided she needs to give
back
so she organized a club at princeton
they adopted a newark high school and
came in fourth in the new jersey
regional this year
so
she'll be due to graduate from your
institution this year
it isn't that complicated everybody you
know
there's way more technology out there
it's not the barrier we have 21st
century technology
we've got to have a 21st century mindset
that we have different problems than we
used to have and we need to adjust the
way we think about them
so that everybody has opportunities to
be part of the solution
and america in particular
it amazes me that we're all used to
getting what we want
everybody wants big things
i think this generation
may not get what it wants
but we may get what we deserve
so
i would
help
and i would stay open-minded about other
technology thank you
hey that's great thank you
thank you again
[Applause]
okay can you hear me all right all right
i'm disappointed dean i wanted to see if
you could sit down in that thing or not
we've got uh exactly 13 minutes for
questions uh for ernie and dean
uh if we will queue up with the two
microphones if you keep the question
short i'll actually keep the answers
short and we'll just go back and forth
sir
hi i just want to say thanks to dean for
starting the first competition i'm from
hartford connecticut and we've had a
regional competition there for a number
of years and it's really amazing not
just to see the kids doing the uh
technical details with the uh mentors
but to see the people cheerleading them
it's just like it really is just like uh
and it's i originally found it
surprising to see that kids would cheer
for something as technical as this but
it's really great and
i i
say to other mit alumni like myself uh
you know try to get involved with it and
whether it be a supporter financially or
as a mentor or through the
students
um it's really something great to
support and because we need more
technical people as you said uh you know
160 000 or whatever versus a couple
million that's a big gap
well thank you for that comment uh we'll
go over here
thank you very much
yeah quick question on the first program
is there a way for students who are not
in school to participate in that
there is a way for everybody to
participate i'll give you my card you
got to put the mic up i think
there's a way for everybody to
participate we need mentors at every
event
there's no limit to what we need and if
you are a person frankly who's got any
technical capability a little bit of
passion
we need you i guess my question is when
you talk about organizing through the
schools is there a way for students who
are not in school too
we probably had 30 of the thousand teams
at the robotics competition were home
school
groups that got together and probably 15
of the 4 100 schools or 4 100 teams that
came to the first lego league were
homeschoolers okay good thank you
thank you question hi dean
first of all i have to say of a great
product my high school son brought home
a couple of units from our local car
dealership
and uh we we used them for the weekend
they were great
unfortunately i haven't yet written the
check and they had to go back to the car
dealership
but my question is so
i could see
very dense urban areas might have a
concern where uh if 95
of the entities on the sidewalk are
going two miles an hour and five percent
are going eight miles an hour but uh
have you um been pushing uh for them to
be used more in areas with bike lanes
and maybe not quite as dense areas where
the sidewalks aren't packed quite as
tight
if i had to
if i could go back and change some of
the things we did
i'm not sure it would have come out
better or worse or no different
i might have thought about going to the
bike people in the bike lanes because
much to our at least my shock amazement
and surprise
there was negative
uh
response not by the car people who i
would have anticipated it from none at
all they realized we don't compete with
the car you're not going to buy this
instead of a car
you don't buy sneakers instead of a car
i didn't realize why but perhaps by not
consulting them the bike people who i
thought would see this us as an ally
another opportunity to get cars out of
the middle of their city
i thought that if we went and asked to
be on bike lanes they'd say we're way
too slow
they work for three generations to get
this space we're gonna just walk in and
use it so i thought we were doing a
courtesy of saying where a pedestrian
will live with pedestrians and unlike a
bike if pedestrians are crowded which is
very rare by the way the show just let
out we can stop we can back up we go at
the same speed we mix well with the
crowd typically there's no crowd so we
come along so i will admit that we never
talked early on to the bike people we as
a consequence perhaps did not get their
support maybe it's not too late i don't
think we belong on a bike lane we are
pedestrians uh if enough people do this
the cities will accommodate it by making
lanes for it but you certainly can't
preemptively ask for lanes for it just
let them be if if they're not
a lot of them around it won't matter
the 1500 cars he's proud to get rid of
well fifteen hundred of these would get
lost in this city and eliminate fifteen
hundred car starts every couple hours if
a lot of people start using them the
infrastructure will adopt the way we now
stack cars up in five level buildings
okay thank you we'll go over here
just a quick comment to dean i i i
skated for about a mile alongside a
person using your device
and
noticed that potholes were a big problem
for them so
the bike lanes have got potholes those
have to be very neatly filled in before
we can even consider it then there's
still a speed differential problem
but
my
question actually is for the young
looking
professor of physics
there's an article
in what matters the mit alumni
publication in march
which suggests electrify guideways is
the culmination of our surface
transportation developments over the
next few decades
uh why didn't you talk about that and
what do you think of it
young looking professor of physics
who's that right anyway uh
well again i'm i'm addressing really the
if you like the
large-scale
transportation
issue and
i frankly as i said in my talk
uh just believe that the
infrastructure
and intrinsic advantages
uh to the uh
current paradigm and current fuels uh
it's just not going to
admit a very large transformation
over several decades yeah well the
electrified guideways would be powered
directly by electricity off the grid so
it's a paradigm that wasn't really
discussed here today it's
i believe it is net less efficient
first of all
please
as an african-american as an
african-american engineer let me applaud
your your first program again and uh i
wish you all the best i'm gonna
participate next year um
the question about your segway uh and
another another disruptive technology
bicycles um after seeing beijing and the
seas of cyclists running around their
pigeons
um
what it was for the segway house are we
comparing to this
well as as the speaker accurately
pointed out a bicycle
even in in china with is this huge
density of people standing a bicycle
doesn't fit with that it it doesn't stop
or back up or spin and plays like a
crowd of people and it doesn't fit very
well with the trucks and buses that were
out there and and we've had a hundred
and somewhat 125 years in this country
to try to figure out how to make them
work together and most reasonable people
even the passionate people that love
bicycles and certainly in many ways a
bicycle if you can use it and have the
help it is exercise it is faster it is
cheaper but the passionate people even
recognize their bicycles don't belong
mixing with pedestrians for the obvious
reasons of their size and their length
and their shape and their operating
characteristics and they certainly
unfortunately wouldn't do well
having an interaction with a bus at 40
miles an hour so we need for bicycles to
work a separate infrastructure for them
i think we should put them in everywhere
that's that's a complimentary and not an
alternative
modality but if anything those pictures
prove to me that a bicycle is not going
to be the solution in a pedestrian
environment if a hundred of the people
you saw in that
intense
crowd or on segways you wouldn't know it
it works very well and then when they
get out of that they can cruise along at
a reasonable speed and each one of them
is now using a legitimate alternative to
a car or a bike
inside a highly dense environment of a
city
thank you let's get one here
dean this question is about the
infrastructure needed for suburban
segway users
i'm sure you'll be amused to know i live
in the washington dc area and i have a
22 pound electric scooter that i ride
from home to a mile to a bus stop and
then i
pick it up and carry it on the bus and
take it to a subway that i take to go
downtown
it's very easy for me to carry this
scooter around but i'm not sure it'd be
as easy to carry a segway onto a bus and
then down to a subway station
do you have thoughts as to what it would
take to put in place an infrastructure
that would make it practical to use
the sub the segway in addition to other
forms of public transportation
i have half an answer to your particular
problem and a general answer to the rest
you said bus and subway
there was actually a specific case of a
woman who
rode went on to a subway in in
washington and was told she couldn't do
it
there was a legal issue over it because
we had gone through the trouble of
washington dc is i'm counting among the
45 places where we are expressly legal
and she won and we are now allowed by
right
not only on their
sidewalks but to drive into their
subways so that's an easy one because
you stand on it like every other strap
hanger except it just helps you a little
bit because it's dynamically stabilizing
you
we can't practically get them on a bus
a
there are easy ways if you were serious
about it to make public transportation
like a bus
compatible with them b you could avoid
the bus piece or many people can and c
in reality uh just like 50 percent of
the cars running around major cities
manhattan or taxi cabs fleets of these
that might be in it would be a whole lot
easier to get the political
and social clout to say we're going to
make this congested 10 square block area
in a downtown quote pedestrian only if
people knew that that meant there'll be
a few thousand of these things
to just bop around there so making a
different model of their accessibility
making different technologies that can
carry them and changing slightly your
root profile hopefully will allow them
at least for a reasonable number of
people to be part of the solution
i'm sorry but we're only going to have
time for one more question so we'll give
it to you sir
i'm sorry uh this is a question
regarding the segway and similar to the
other infrastructure question
um
a lot of our cities and neighborhoods
are designed now especially those built
in the last 30 40 years designed for
automobiles
and
you know the engineers doing their best
to make that all fit into
what we do
i was wondering if you had taken a look
at newer neighborhoods a la sun city
type situations where they're starting
from scratch
and
finding a place for that type of
transportation in those areas
the really good news
i will i'll take exception to the
statement that in the last 30 or 40
years cities have been designed for cars
i think in the last 30 or 40 years
the forces
to prevent the ultimate demise of the
city seem to be
they lost out
the good news is most major cities in
the world were finished the concrete was
set before the car was invented
the car
is now
wreaking havoc but it's a reversible
effect
los angeles for instance could be argued
as a community that was built post car
and yes it was designed that way
but the two good pieces of news
most major cities in the world that
already exist
were architected for a highly dense
environment and would do better if cars
weren't in their downtown even as we
stand here today if you could give
people a good alternative and that's
where most of those billions of people
are
second places like sun city and
retirement communities and gated
communities are ideal for segway because
if you look at the planned view of most
of these places
most
of their planned view is pavement the
last crop you're ever going to grow is
asphalt and even in these very expensive
places where real estate is a premium
they're building them in such a way now
that a we're already very compatible if
you said we're illegal for instance most
suburban environments in the last 20
years have been built with no sidewalk
structure zero but these gated
communities all have these alternatives
so in the new gated community sun city
we win
but the really really big answer to me
is
in that
set of cities that's going to take the
800 million people that will change life
as we know it if they all want cars and
they have as much right to a car as you
do
if you look at the next 20 or 30 years
of building cities and could say to
people architect your city assuming it's
not going to be
a high density human environment however
stripped and ripped apart by these
mechanical boxes full of people
allow your city to
to be architected and zoned
knowing that a hyper pedestrian that
will move as fast as that car could have
taken them in these areas
if even five percent of the new cities
do that it will make as much of an
impact as all the stuff we were looking
at today
well i'm sorry we're going to cut off
the questions here because we are out of
time i think keith is going to make just
a brief closing remark before he does
that
would you join me in thanking our
panelists for a terrific
norm thank you very much
now i first came across augustine's laws
by being a member of this committee and
i'm going to share since we're all
sharing our favorites i'll share one of
my favorites with you which as i recall
was projects generally start out slowly
and taper off from there
and that's something that we in
technology see often but uh the tech day
program i think has been the exception
that proves the rule for us it has
really been a just a wonderful
experience all around norm ernie dean
thanks to each of you
uh one more joke for you all
when i die i want to go in my sleep like
my uncle not yelling and screaming like
the passengers in his car
yeah okay we're back to problems right
um
my buddy eric vesper another alumni
refers to mit as a place for the
terminally curious and this passion for
understanding is demonstrated by the
fact that on such a gorgeous day so many
of you came back to in the afternoon
after lunch
to hear
these wonderful thoughts from our
speakers
rather than being out in your vehicles
enjoying the big dig traffic rerouting
and flashing red lights and so forth
um one reminder
survey forms if you do them we really
appreciate it
and i'll leave you with this thought
doug vincent who will be chairing the
committee beginning in about 60 seconds
or so um made us all think about the
point of tech day as he served on the
committee this year you know we all know
what it is but but why do we do it and
doug's contention which i think he's
made us all converts to
was that our opportunity and really our
obligation is to bring in the brightest
minds we can find to share their
insights with a motivated group of
thought leaders all of you folks who can
go out and make a difference and i feel
like we've done that this year and i
have every expectation that doug and the
committee will do it again next year so
drive light and we'll see you then
cheers